wanting to have a side hustle wanting to
have this is all about your own personal
needs which are irrelevant to the market
the market does not care Daniel has
written five books all about
entrepreneurship and business and stuff
in particular oversubscribed is the book
that I have most highlighted on Kindle
out of any book I have ever read and his
whole library of books essentially
starting with the entrepreneur
Revolution gives a very legit and
systematic playbook for how you can
start the business from basically
wherever you are with a full-time job
without having to give too much time to
it as an entrepreneur you're kind of
asking the question what is the problem
I'm trying to solve in the world there's
a group of people out there they've got
an unmet need they're frustrated there's
something that they're not happy about
and then I'm going to come along and
solve that holistically for them we also
talk a little bit about Daniel's
backstory from how the age of 19 he got
a job at a startup started his own
company at 21 became a multi-millionaire
by the age of like 23. super super
interesting stuff I hope you enjoyed
this interview as much as I did just a
very quick thing before we get started
if you have not yet subscribed to to the
podcast either on YouTube or in your
favorite podcast app of choice then
please do it really helps us out a lot
well Daniel thank you so much for being
here it's really nice to see you in the
flesh because uh your book
oversubscribed is uh the most
highlighted book I have ever highlighted
of all time on Kindle of like hundreds
of books in my library amazing basically
almost every other paragraph in this I
was like oh my God this is so good just
select oh just select all yeah and there
was a bit at the end where you say hey
one of these chapters I wasn't even
planning to include in the books and
it's up to you to figure out which one I
was was like but all of it all of it is
just sick anyway um you've written a
bunch of these books um you know the
entrepreneur Revolution scorecard
marketing key person of influence 24
assets key person of influence is also
quite influential amongst the sort of
Creator space yeah around like building
a business around around an individual
personal brand yeah all that kind of
stuff um but before we dive into all the
business stuff I'd love to open with how
how did we end up here you and I talking
to each other you're from Australia
originally like what was the what was
the backstory yeah I kind of did
retirement first uh I grew up in a beach
location called mooloolaba in Australia
which is like just a beautiful beach
um and a small town uh and um uh I had
the opportunity when I was 19 years old
to join a startup and basically I joined
this startup when there's three of us
around a table there's no bank account
there's no business name it's just we're
going to be starting a startup this guy
who's 37 years old who's previously had
businesses he's going to be launching
something and I'm 19 and I'm like okay
I'm joining something because I just
dropped out of University and
um and it was really exciting and it was
like oh wow okay what's what's going to
happen and then over the next two years
it really took off fast so
um we went from you know zero to I think
six million in two years we went to 60
people so from a Beachside location to
60 people in a city Melbourne offices
so
is it a marketing agency and um uh it
was very much focused on event marketing
and um event marketing yeah so well what
what like when Tony Robbins an event he
hires a marketing agency to get people
to go filling events yeah bums on seats
yeah and partnering with different
people and Brands to fill their events
Brisbane Sydney Melbourne so that that
was this uh exciting first start I had
to um being in business and I had this
amazing relationship with the founder
John
um where I was always under his wing and
learning and learning and he would
recommend books and he'd recommend these
crazy challenges for me to complete so I
had to keep a journal I had to stop
watching news you know no no news I had
to carry a thousand dollars in my pocket
there was all these kind of weird things
that he got me to do uh over the over
the period of building that business
and then two years in I go to John and I
say
um I would really like some shares in
the business because I was here at the
beginning and I you know I've set up
this subdivision this Regional Division
and you know I'm doing all the right
things and I called him at the wrong
time I remember vividly he was loading
boxes into the back of his car and I'm
asking him about chairs in the business
and um and he says dan if you want
shares in a business go start your own
so so I did uh at 21 years old I went
and started my own company I replicated
everything I learned from John and I
basically copied the business model I
knew it was the only thing I knew I went
and launched my own business and it took
off and it went really fast growth so
I'm not your own marketing agency yeah
event marketing um and basically the the
whole business model was lead generation
for companies that want lead generation
and introduction events what is lead
generation for the unfamiliar yeah so
lead generation is where you get someone
to signal that they're interested in
doing business with you right so if you
think about it like a financial planner
they could try and sell Financial
Planning and like literally say here's
how much it is or they could say take an
online scorecard and fill that in and
then people that's a signal of interest
and that person is a lead and another
way to generate a lead is through an
event so you could put on a weekly event
called an introduction to financial
planning or an introduction to Building
Wealth for retirement so that is what I
talk about in the book as a product for
prospects or a lead generation product
and so my first business was all about
creating these introduction events and
what we'd do is we'd partner with
established businesses and they were
rightly focused on their core business
but they didn't really have a lot of
time for focusing on lead generation so
we would do these introduction events
an introduction to you know whatever it
was introduction to blank and we'd run
these weekly events up and down Brisbane
Sydney Melbourne like in real life yeah
in real life back in back back before
Zoo yeah you know back before YouTube
real life events yeah yeah like this was
before Myspace yeah uh so we're going
right way back so we would just have
these Live Events running
um in 2016 six
no 2005 sorry uh I did 174 live events
that year we did 10.7 million in Revenue
um and it was year three how okay how
does a company like this make money
uh so several different ways so we would
get paid sometimes per lead that we
would generate sometimes we'd get paid
per sale that would come through
um the difference was is that most
agencies love to do FIFA service pay me
10 grand and then pay me this per week
retainers and all that what I did which
I learned from John
was a risk to reward uh deal so I would
actually take the risk on running these
introduction events and I would profit
share or Revenue share with the
companies so
my very first day launching my business
was a newspaper ad that was I think
seven thousand dollars for a quarter
page ad I put it on my credit card I had
no way of paying for that other than if
leads came in and we made sales uh so
that was the launch of my business on a
credit card taking out a quarter page ad
so really scary kind of stuff how did
you have the conviction to to do that
that like even I wouldn't do that and I
think I'm a fairly risk-taking kind of
guy well it didn't feel super risky
because I'd been doing it non-stop for
two years with John uh and I had
actually just before leaving his
business I'd set up a regional events
marketing business so they were doing
Brisbane Sydney Melbourne and I started
with Tasmania and
um a place called Geelong and Bendigo
and Ballarat and all these kind of weird
places that are a few hours drive out of
a major city
and um I had basically been placing ads
in their newspapers and running
introduction
uh presentations introduction events and
I'd been through the motions
non-stop for two years so for me you
were pretty seasoned at the thing I felt
like yeah I was going through emotions
that were familiar but oh my goodness it
felt different at the time when you're
putting money on your own credit card
versus the boss's credit card how does
it okay so a question on this front do a
lot of young people want to start their
own businesses
um to what extent do you think it's
useful to join an existing startup
versus just start your own and have a
punt and kind of do it anyway it's it's
massively useful to join someone else's
startup like I would highly recommend
that to absolutely anyone so here's what
goes wrong with a lot of young people
they go to careers fairs and all that
sort of stuff it's only big corporates
that exhibit so they end up being
funneled down the big corporate uh uh
path now you can start a business that
doesn't exist you can go to a big
corporate so in the UK there are 7 000
large companies that have more than 250
employees there's 5.5 million businesses
in the middle that all already exist but
don't have 250 employees so and the vast
majority of them have 10 people or less
right so it's huge hugely stacked
between 2 and 10 people is the small
business landscape so when you join a
big corporate you have no idea what the
whole business does you know have no
idea what everyone else does
um they don't bring you in on strategy
or any of that sort of stuff you are
just completely in the dark and they say
this is your job go do that job and if
you can't do it we'll find someone else
who can is the subtext but when you join
a business that's four people five
people six people you know exactly what
the whole company does you you often
know the revenue you often know the
profit you often know the weekly
activity of the entire team so you get
this kind of feeling and experience of
what an entire team does and what an
entire business does and I I would
highly recommend anyone who wants to
start a business
first do two years working inside
somebody else's small business oh
interesting so like a lot of people
um sort of in our team want to talk to
them about this or people have done
internships with us feel like say that
oh yeah you know I I feel like I'm
learning a lot
and to me I'm always a bit can be like
like what is what is there to learn like
because we're just like doing stuff but
I guess for someone who doesn't have
experience running a business or being
in or yeah it's completely different to
life in Amazon HQ corporate and it's
also not too different to what you did
with medicine where you know you do your
study and you do your education and then
you go and work in hospital and you're
working around experienced doctors you
know and like the theory is all well and
good but like the two first two weeks on
the job when you realize oh this is the
dynamic between the nurses and this is
how you request a scan and this is how
you do all this other stuff that you
never it's yeah
and here's how long this actually takes
and you know these little things that
you like in a business context flipping
back from medicine which I know nothing
about uh you know just things like uh
well how do you send out like a big bulk
email to a list or where do you get a
list from or like how do you sit down
and have a lunch and negotiate a joint
venture so for me my two is doing that
when I was 19 to 21 I actually got to
sit in on those meetings so when John
was negotiating to do a list swap you
mail your list for our product and will
mail our list for your product I'm
sitting in on that meeting quietly and
going oh wow that's how that happened
that's the thing yeah yeah and when John
was proposing oh here's what we'll do
with the revenue we'll do a revenue
split and we'll actually this will be
the first chunk for costs and we'll take
that out first and then this will be and
here's how we'll measure it and it's
like oh right okay that's just a meeting
that you have and you just agree that in
the meeting and then you write it down
and confirm it and then you put it in
the heads of terms yeah okay now I get
it
yeah I think the similar stuff like this
where until you've had experience in a
thing it's just it's hard to even fathom
what goes on like this weekend I was at
this like philanthropy conferencing type
thing where there were people from like
nuclear policy making and like Grant
making and I was I was asking all the
basic questions I was like like what
what does it mean to like Lobby a
congressman and they're like oh you
literally queue up and then you
literally give the money for and wait
what that's a thing like how how do you
contact a government official do you
just like Google their name and they're
like well no it's opaque for a reason
and you have to do this you have to like
it's just completely mind-blowing that
this whole world of like government and
policy and grants and philanthropy that
I have zero experience in and like I can
read all the books but I I wouldn't know
how to contact a government official
yeah unless I know someone who's
literally doing the thing yeah and you
hear these fancy titles it's like oh I'm
an analyst with
um kpmj or Goldman Sachs and it's like
but what do you actually do oh I get
given a list of these people and then I
have to go and put these spreadsheets
together oh okay yeah
okay so you're 21 you've started your
own I guess lead generation company Okay
so
is this like let's say I am an estate
agent and I want to sell houses I'll
give you some real examples we worked
with um financial planners we worked
with franchisors one of the biggest
deals we did was with franchisors who
wanted to sell franchises and what we'd
do is a road show of events introducing
their franchise to potential franchisees
um now as a sixty thousand dollar
franchise we would get uh 15 of the
franchise success fee
um as our marketing fee okay so they
paid us
um an amount that covered costs first
and then we got 15 successfully on on
top of that so that was a great deal
they'd put a lot of energy and effort
into creating a franchise we
um they when when I met them
I went to a franchise Expo and there
were 300 franchisors all trying to say
that they had the best franchise and my
child's always in like the Five Guys
McDonald's KFC would be a franchisor
yeah exactly and they're like those are
like McDonald's is the biggest
well-known franchise they sell you the
rights to run their business but there's
all sorts of little franchises like
mortgage broking franchises and even
things like gardening franchises and
cleaning franchises so
um you you basically I go along to a
franchise Expo and I see that there's
300 franchisors trying to stand out and
be different and I go this doesn't work
for anyone because if you're a customer
thinking about buying a franchise you've
now got way too many choices and if
you're a franchisor you're just standing
right next to 300 competitors so it's
just feeling too weird like two you know
two
um
uh it feels too saturated so we just
basically approached one that I thought
was great and we negotiated deal and we
did a road show where instead of them
being shoulder to shoulder with
competitors we would put them in front
of 50 people who were potential
customers how would you find these 50
people so we'd advertise do Direct Mail
campaigns we would do
um uh there was something called fax
broadcasting at the time facts
broadcasting okay let's not even go I'd
have to I'd have to even begin by
telling your audience what a fax machine
is just a quick message from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by Heights Heights is a
brain care smart supplement it is two
capsules that you take every day I've
been taking it for the last 12 months
and it contains over 20 evidence-based
micronutrients that you need to keep
your brain and body healthy like I said
I've been taking Heights every day for
the last 12 months and through that I've
actually become friends with the founder
Dan who we actually had on season one of
this podcast and this season we also
have an interview with neuroscientist
and psychiatrist Tara swart who is the
chief science officer at Heights as well
and one of the things I love about
Heights is the fact that every single
thing they do is very evidence-based
over on their blog on their website
they've got tons of Articles along with
links to all of the different papers
that they've cited that show all the
benefits of the various micronutrients
that they've got in these two little
capsules and the best thing about taking
these is that it's just two little
capsules every morning so you don't have
to deal with green sludge or any other
kind of faffrey it's just literally
taking two pills it's super easy to sign
up you just go on the website you put in
your address and they send you either a
monthly or a quarterly subscription I
sign up to the quarterly one myself
because a it's cheaper and B I'd have to
take fewer deliveries and if you use a
coupon code Ali 15 at checkout that will
give you 15 off the already discounted
price of the quarterly subscription so
you can try out Heights to your heart's
content so thank you so much Heights for
sponsoring this episode and for helping
improve my own brain care
just a quick message from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by short form short form
is the world's best service that
summarizes books but it's way more than
just book summaries they almost have a
whole study guide for every book that
they've got on the platform where
they've got a one-page summary and then
they also have chapter by chapter
breakdowns and it's not just chapter by
chapter breakdowns also in between the
chapter breakdowns they have interactive
exercises where you can engage more
readily with the ideas in the book short
form covers non-fiction books from a
bunch of different genres that you might
be interested in for example they've got
a load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books in lifestyle
and communication basically any genre of
like non-fiction personal development is
help helpy stuff that will help you
level up your life it's all there on
short form short form Publishers new
book guides and articles every week and
if you're a subscriber then you get to
vote on what book they cover next and in
fact through that that system I have
voted for various books that they've
then turned into summaries for example
one book I recently Revisited is in fact
Rich Dad Poor Dad by Robert Kiyosaki now
I read this book ages and ages and ages
ago I think when I was I was in school
or university and it really shaped the
way that I approach my views of money
but to be honest the book is kind of
basic and it's somewhat out of date but
revisiting the short form summary of it
meant that I could revisit the sort of
abstracted lessons without having to
deal with all of the you know the tone
of the book no offense to Robert is a
little bit a little bit too Brash
whereas a short form summaries it is in
a way a nicer way of getting the same
ideas anyway if any of that sounds up
your street and you would like to sign
up to the world's best service that
summarizes books then head over to
shortform.com forward slash deep dive
and that will give you a completely free
five-day trial and you can try out the
service to your heart's content that
link will also be in the video
description and in the show notes and
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode so okay so
you as the marketing agency are are
trying to you're putting it out in the
newspaper being like do you have 20
grand to spare have you thought about
starting a franchise well no we would do
uh see that's the mistake so what most
big companies do is they promote their
Core Business do you want to buy a
franchise okay so we would what we would
that's not what you want to do no what
we want to do is we want to create an
introduction that is a low risk first
step and it's not necessarily about like
so I'll give you an example from when we
worked with a financial planning company
so they were marketing do you want
Financial Planning and what we would do
is like run events on do you want to
understand the current market do you
want to know what the current trends are
do you want to hear from a financial
planning expert to explain what's going
on in the current market so an
introduction event is just a low risk
first step to introduce the idea now
anyone who turns up to that event
clearly they have an interest in solving
a problem but what we're not doing is
saying do you want to buy my stuff yeah
okay so you give them essentially a load
of free value at the event or like very
cheap value and then some proportion of
those will be like oh by the way this
exactly so but yeah by the way if you
would like to talk to one of our
financial planners there's a diary up
the back of the room and you can book a
meeting one-to-one and just head up and
put your name in the diary and there's
all the slots are highlighted that you
can go and just fill your name literally
with a pen and paper and that was a big
part of what we did right so it was
putting on an interesting speaker
and getting 50 to 100 people to come
along to that and then inviting people
to put their name in the diary and then
you either get paid based on how many
people put the name in the in the diary
or if or how many of those then convert
to a paid customer for the financial
planner yep yep so we would do a
combination of success fees based on
leads or sales wow okay so when you're
now mind you we're going way back in
time I'm 41 now so
so he's taught this lead lead generation
marketing business and you you said you
were doing sort of 10 million plus we
got to 10.7 million within how long
three years bloody hell how did that
feel as a 24 year old at the time doing
that kind of thing it was pretty wild it
was a lot of stress
um it was I mean we had a huge team well
when I say huge team we had we had about
20 of us working out of a massive seven
bedroom house
um you know I was 24 I was buying uh
like a brand new BMW X5 which I wasn't
able to really even ensure and you know
things like that
um I you know I traveled constantly
Brisbane Sydney Melbourne I stayed in
five-star hotels and ate in Michelin
star restaurants because we were taking
clients out and all of those kind of
things sometimes I would be staying in
Sydney and wouldn't bother checking out
of the hotel because I was ducking down
to Melbourne for one night and like it
was crazy we were doing a million a
month in sales so and we're very
profitable
uh so it was a pretty amazing first
start to life you know one of the
lessons I got from my first Mentor John
is that success doesn't have to it can
happen quite quickly right it doesn't
have to be this long road that actually
if you tap into a trend you can push the
door and it can fling right open
um so a lot of the message that
entrepreneurs get is that oh you've got
to really grind it out and you've got to
crawl across glass and you know and then
you can make one dollar and then you can
make ten dollars and you know we did a
couple of million in the first year with
John and then we're doing six million in
year two so it was in my head that it
can happen quite quickly okay yeah
that's interesting yeah because that
very much is the prevailing entrepreneur
narrative and that's certainly The
Narrative I peddle when it comes to
creators and like YouTubers and stuff
where compounding yeah compounding and
long-term growth and if you expect
Revenue within six months as a YouTuber
it's like oh you you might be kind of
aiming for the wrong sorts of things
um in in what ways like the
entrepreneurship stuff different to that
so there are some businesses that are
compounding businesses and there are
businesses that are what's called A J
curve a J curve is where it loses money
before it goes up
um okay so and that's the the shape of
the cash flow is the J right that's what
the J stands for it doesn't stand for
anything that begins with Jay it's it's
the shape of losing money and then
making money so that's called a J curve
business and the J curve business a lot
of the time is like technology so let's
say you spend a million dollars building
something uh of tech related and then
you sell it for 10 pounds a month ten
dollars a month right keep jumping
between dollars and pounds
um but uh you would have what's called a
naturally occurring J curve you've spent
all this money to build something and
now you've got someone paying ten
dollars a month now you've got 10 people
paying 10 a month so now the J curve
starts I know you're compounding and
you're yeah and hopefully you get to the
point where oh when we hit 5 000 people
then we break even and then when we hit
10 000 it's all profit and you know so
that's the J curve and the uptick of the
J is what you're hoping for that's why
you're in it in the first place
but you've got to get through the J so
that's that's a lot of business models
are naturally occurring J curves setting
up a restaurant as a J curve like large
expense to set it up and then you need
to hit a certain threshold of customers
to right even yeah you've got to hit
volumes yeah right so a restaurant you
know the average spend might be thirty
dollars per person so you've got to have
a lot of people coming so that's a J
curve business there are other
businesses that are not necessarily J
curves like for example Consulting you
could sign up one Consulting client who
spends 80 grand a year with you uh and
like you've got almost no overhead and
straight away You're Consulting and
let's say you get four clients and now
you're making you know hundreds of
thousands and you have very little
overhead and you might hire an assistant
or you might you know do something like
that you might work on their site so for
example I know people who are
Consultants to manufacturing companies
and they optimize the manufacturing
process and they actually look for
what's called lean systems and they get
paid hundreds of thousands to go and do
manufacturing Consulting they work on
site
um very low overheads that's not a J
curve business yeah yeah that's that
that's so interesting so so two two
thoughts on this um I think the the
business of quote being a content
creator or doing the YouTube channel or
whatever thing
is definitely a Jayco business
um even if you're not spending any money
on it it's definitely a Jacob in terms
of the time because you're a massive
like sinking so much time into the thing
exactly before you hit the monetization
threshold and now all of those assets
that you've spent years building up are
now still compounding and then you get
to stupid levels but it's like people
get disgruntled and discouraged because
they're sinking in the time and
generally while they're a student or
while they've got a full-time job yeah
and they're not seeing a return straight
away whereas
and I think it's it's a lot less like
I listen to a bunch of business podcasts
and I generally don't hear about
non-jcove businesses like I've I've got
a friend from from University who does
this manufacturing Consulting for
fashion companies because he's into like
Ai and sort of coding and stuff and
loves fashion and understands how
fashion supply chain works and gets like
stupidly large amounts of money for a
single Consulting Arrangement
um and he's just he's just making money
he doesn't have an audience he's not
trying to do the whole YouTube thing
he's just making money from day one
exactly and you just don't hear about
those sorts of businesses and so people
who are like oh I want to maybe start a
business on the side or automatically
feel like oh I have to sync two years of
free F free work into this thing before
I can make money yeah and you do if it's
a J curve but not if it's not uh so the
typically the difference is the sales
process so A J curve business normally
relies on almost a frictionless sale
where people either do a free free piece
of content or they do a free trial
um or they sit down at a restaurant
expecting to spend you know 30 or
something like that so it's fairly
friction unless the non-j curve
businesses normally have a sales process
so you're sitting down with a potential
client and you're actually convincing
them to part with a sizable chunk of
cash and normally it would be thousands
to tens of thousands per sale
and you need to generate leads and then
you need to make the sale so you have to
you know sit down with that fashion
business and say look here's how your
current system works here's some of the
best practices that you're leaving off
at the table and you might sell an
initial scope of work that is like fact
find or something like that and then you
present that and you come back and now
you're presenting a piece of work that
can also turn into a boutique so you
could have three to twelve people
working together doing supply chain
Consulting together and all of that you
know everyone can be making great money
you know in those types of businesses so
anything that involves a sales process
is normally a non-j curve business
interesting
um what where does a freelancer fit into
this yeah so freelancer is self-employed
and it's not a model that I think is a
great model so you're essentially Chief
cook and bottle washer you're doing
strategy and implementation and finance
and scheduling and all of that sort of
stuff
um and essentially what you're doing is
you're charging a premium because people
don't have to commit to a long package
so what tends to work entrepreneurially
is to not get caught up as a freelancer
selling your own labor right let's just
zoom out a little bit the school system
teaches us to be component labor so when
we go to school right the whole thing is
about everything is based off the
Industrial Revolution model and most
people end up as a component in a larger
system so we get taught how to become a
piece of component labor so when we
freelance we're essentially selling
ourselves as component labor to someone
else who has a bigger outcome in mind
right but we're just doing that ad hoc
now the trick about being an
entrepreneur is to separate from the
mindset of being component labor and to
actually move across to being outcome
focused and looking at what is the
customer trying to get done what does
the customer want why is that customer
buying this what's the payoff for them
radical empathy with the customer and
then saying I will build you a solution
that you want and I will find the
components whatever they are and I'll
put those together and sell you that and
it may well be you doing the thing at
the start but they don't have to know
that but you could well you could
potentially be a piece of Labor however
the better option
is to have some expertise
such that you know how to organize other
people's labor so that you like if
you've got the knowledge of how let's
use this as an example right if you've
got the knowledge of how supply chain
should function you should be able to
organize a team of three or four people
who know how to optimize that and you
should be able to select the right
people and then you you're better off
actually being the key person of
influence up on stage telling stories
um winning the deals uh writing a book
about it putting a podcast out there
about it and then having a team Who
deliver the actual outcome but the trick
is that you want to as quick as possible
avoid being a component in somebody
else's system and actually be someone
who stands for an outcome and someone
who's an expert in either talking about
that outcome selling that outcome
overseeing that outcome putting together
teams that know about that outcome yeah
and so
let's say uh so just use a concrete
example um I know a bunch of people who
um
are interested in writing uh they've
maybe done liking your English degrees
or something don't really want maybe
they've tried Consulting for a year or
two and freaking hate it and they love
the idea of you know live my dream
remote digital Nomad life work from
anywhere type stuff on my laptop become
a quick freelance writer would be how oh
like the default path would be I need to
get a normal job the the next to default
path would be I should become a
freelance writer but it sounds like like
how how would you be thinking about that
to maybe think more entrepreneurially so
let's start with the downside the
downside is that that sounds lovely and
we love thinking about doing the work so
the freelance writer loves the idea of
sitting in Bali with the laptop and
doing the freelance writing one of the
issues is is that in order to do the
work we love we have to win the work
that we love so now you're asking the
question well okay I know you can do the
writing piece but are you going to be
able to win the significant number of
clients necessary in order to do that
now for most businesses winning the
clients is going to be 30 40 50 of the
time you're going to be constantly
hustling for a client so what you can do
if you're a freelancer is you could try
and find four or five companies that
need regular work and you split your
time between them and really what you're
hoping for is that each one pays a
slight premium
and they they're not worried about your
flexibility that you can work from Bali
so that's the total upside package that
you're looking for maybe splitting your
time between four
um yeah and you're hoping for a retainer
or something so you've got a regular
income coming in and whereas you might
have been paid 50 Grand if you split it
up between several you might get 60 or
70 grand right and you might get time
flexibility or for you know that sort of
thing so it's it's okay the downsides
are significant you know you don't have
a real career path unless you invent one
and
um you can easily have you know lack
motivation because you're not in an
environment that's dictating you know a
level of performance you're having to
create those elements yourself you can
get caught up in things like finances
and paying taxes and chasing up invoice
chasing invoices all of those things
suddenly you realize that you've got all
of the downsides of having a business
without the upside scalability
you've all you've got all of the
downsides of having a job without the
security of a job right so freelancing
to me is not necessarily a great idea
because it comes with a lot of the
downsides without the upsides okay so
using this right for example how might
they level up their thinking and think
more entrepreneurially well you could
create a writing agency you could
um create
um uh packages of content intellectual
property that you've created that you
can then resell and on sale you could
create your own
written assets which get used in any
number of ways so you can create
licensable assets so there is stuff like
that the difference is though you have
to stop thinking like a technician a
technician is someone who's gonna
component labor they're gonna you know
do a job for money you've got to start
thinking about an entrepreneur which is
what problem am I trying to solve in the
world so it all starts as an
entrepreneur you're kind of asking the
question what is the problem I'm trying
to solve in the world like there's a
group of people out there they've got an
unmet need they're frustrated there's
something that they're not happy about
and then I'm going to come along and
solve that holistically for them I'm
going to come up with a full solution
full and remarkable solution for them
and that's gonna solve that for them and
I'm going to organize labor systems IP
technology all of that's going to be
organized and we're going to put that
together
so yeah I'm not thinking
I want to be a freelance writer I'm
thinking what is the problem that I can
solve well the problem the the the issue
is if you're a freelance writer thinking
about I'm a freelance writer and here's
what I want to do you're essentially
you're your own customer you're thinking
about your own needs and your own
problems and that's the opposite to
where entrepreneurs need to think
entrepreneurs need to park their own
needs and their own problems in order to
research what somebody else needs so in
your example of going to this franchise
or Expo realizing that hey there's 300
people out there you in instead of
thinking I want I want to be a lead gen
person running events you were thinking
what is the problem these guys have and
how can I build a business to solve that
problem yeah so I was marrying up a set
of skills that I had Acquired and a
business model that I knew with looking
at these people really clearly
frustrated that we've paid all this
money to come to this show and you know
we're just surrounded by competitors
okay
and so
how
what was your relationship to money like
the in the around that time if you can
remember sort of age 19 you start
working for this starter Bureau earning
a salary and then suddenly you're sort
of making like Millions doing your own
thing yeah so as a university student
um I was properly broke
um to the extent that I would uh you
know go to the Butcher and see if they
had offcuts that were going cheap that
day
um and I would go to the veggie store
and get a box of like horrible
vegetables that were you know going like
for two dollars a box
um I was a Pizza Hut delivery driver on
three dollars a delivery
um I was
um uh late night barmen I was doing
door-to-door sales for a roof insulation
company setting appointments like I was
doing whatever I could to just simply
survive and I would work if I wasn't
doing uni I was working and I was like
completely just
trying to optimize every spare moment
and making maybe like a thousand maybe
fifteen hundred dollars a month just
enough to cover rent and I was living
with five people in a three bedroom
house
so all of those sorts of things so I had
a real you know the evidence that I had
was that money was very scarce very hard
to come by and that you know this was
something that was just how it was right
everyone I knew was in that position as
well
so one of the questions that happened
with my mentor was he said to me
um Daniel how much do you think is a lot
of money and I said 52 000 a year right
if you earn a grand a week There's I
remember saying there's not much you
can't do on a grand a week and he kind
of laughed and he said Daniel I'm going
to put you in a sales role and you're
gonna get 10 per sale and if you're only
making 520
000 a year worth of sales I'm gonna fire
you because that's way too little he's
like I need you to be making like 1.2
million a year worth of sales and you
need to be earning 120 000 a year and
I'm like what and this was kind of
radical
but he said to me Dan I think you need
to adjust your psychology around money
um he said I want you to bring me I
think it was a thousand maybe two
thousand I want you to bring me a
thousand dollars tomorrow in cash I'm
like why and he's like you'll see
so I had a little bit of cash in the
bank and I think I might have borrowed
some from Dad I used to run these
nightclub parties um in in University
and like everyone paid in cash and I had
like a little stash of cash so I kind of
brought him a thousand dollars and you
know it was like a lot of money it was
all my money right so he grabs a clip a
bulldog clip and he says carry that in
your pocket at all times I want you to
always have a thousand dollars in your
pocket and I was like oh okay
so for the first couple of weeks I'm
walking around like this is very
dangerous and ninjas are going to come
and get me and people will judge me and
all this sort of stuff and I think I'd
gotten it in hundred dollar notes at
that point so I've got like 10 hundred
dollar notes in my in my pocket
and what was interesting is about two
weeks or three weeks in my brain starts
to adjust that a thousand dollars is
just pocket money it's just the kind of
money you carry on you and my energy
towards money just shifted very rapidly
so
you know when I first was doing sales
calls and I would say you know oh uh you
know this is two thousand dollars it was
like my energy towards two thousand
dollars is like I'm asking you for your
kidney
um yeah and then a couple of weeks later
it's like oh it's you know pocket money
it's not not like my non-verbal
communication my energy towards money
just shifted so radically just by
carrying a bunch of it so
um several things happened it surfaced
up to it brought up to the surface all
of the issues that I had around money so
I'm going to be judged uh if I've got
money people will judge me because I'm
thinking what if somebody sees it what
if they think I'm some sort of high
roller or something what if I'm paying
for something and someone sees my money
clip
um and then it brought up if you have
money people will attack you
um so that was another psychology of
money it's like you're going to be
attacked for having money physically
harmed
um and the other one was like money's
really hard to come by it's a very
scarce resource and it's like you know
getting it is really hard and you have
to hold on to it so all of this kind of
bubbles up to the surface
and um uh and the other one was oh what
if a girl wants to date me because she
thinks I've got lots of money but I
don't have money so it was this whole
idea of like my only value as a man is
like my having money so all of that is
like bubbling and then because it's
bubbling up to the surface you're able
to think about it and process it and
think ah is that the belief I want to
have is that something I like thinking
um so it was a it was a trigger for
dealing with money issues very rapidly
and mind you a thousand dollars back in
2001 2002 was was significantly more if
you want to do the activity today you
probably need a couple of thousand
there's inflation in fact it's going up
ten percent yeah so let's attempt to set
that number um
so this sounds like a pretty cool Mentor
he was great yeah did you have any other
lessons that he taught you in a sort of
somewhat weird manner well well I'll
give you two yeah one was no news so I
was completely banned from the news and
he basically said look the news is just
statistically irrelevant things that
they present to you on a daily basis you
know they're not going to report to you
that a plane landed safely they're not
going to report to you that you know
people woke up and went to work and uh
had a lovely day it's only going to be
the statistically irrelevant things the
things that happened to one in a hundred
thousand people that's the only stuff
that you're going to read in the news
the second thing about the news is none
of it is anything you can do anything
about so you might think it's absolutely
horrible what's happening in a
particular place or a particular
situation that's not you you've got no
ability to influence that so get on with
what you have the ability to do build
your own platform build your own life
and then you might have the ability to
influence more stuff
so
um so one of his rules was a complete
blackout on any form of news newspapers
radio
television just completely gone and that
is quite freeing as well right free
frees up time Freed's up headspace frees
up negative emotions
um so that was great and then the big
lesson I got from John was everything is
Downstream from lead generation so okay
you you can't build a business if you
can't generate leads if you you know you
can have a big audience but if they
can't signal that they're interested in
something you can't build a business you
could have an amazing product that
you've spent 10 years developing if you
can't get people to Signal their
interest in that you've got no business
so he his thing was everything is
Downstream from lead generation almost
everything I learned over those two
years was just lead generation it was
all about how do you generate warm leads
and we you know there was dozens of
different ways that we would go with and
we'd we'd constantly the whole business
was this idea of lead generation and
what was interesting about it
is that when we would blow up a client's
business it was just we turn the lead
generation tap on nothing else changed
you could like you could have a
financial planning business where
they've you know they've been in
business for 15 years and they're
struggling month to month and they're
really good at what they do but they're
you know their business isn't growing
rapidly you blow up the leads you put on
40 events introduction to you know the
markets introduction to investing
and then that business just goes and it
blows up in in no time so everything's
Downstream from lead generation I
literally watched our clients lives
completely change because we turned on
the lead generation tab
yeah I this is this is sparking so many
so many thoughts in my mind around our
own business and like how
like the first time we kind of really
sold something
um this was before I read over
subscribed um it was our kind of high
ticket course and we just sort of
launched it expecting like I don't know
12 people to sign up for like a beta
testing cohort and like 354 people
signed up and just like bloody hell
um yeah but I think that's because we
had four years worth of like almost
pent-up demand for this thing but then
every time we've run it since it's felt
like harder and harder it's felt like
we've exhausted some of the warm
audience more and more and now it feels
like we're having to do more to generate
those leads
um but I guess like in my mind I'm not
even thinking of it as as lead
generation
um yeah Ali imagine this you've got
three and a half million subscribers
most people don't have 3 000 people on a
database so whatever you're feeling and
experiencing most small businesses are
completely crushed by this problem this
lead generation problem is a crushing
problem that impacts every area of their
life
um prevents them from taking holidays
prevents them from ever switching off on
the weekend you know so if you take most
of those five billion businesses out
there in the UK the lead generation
problem is the big problem like they
have no ability to generate leads just a
quick note from one of our sponsors and
we'll get right back to the episode and
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by skillshare if you haven't heard
by now skillshare is probably the single
best place in the world to learn
anything online and the best thing about
skillshare sponsoring this podcast is
it's very exciting because I have
actually been a teacher on skillshare
since 2019 and I actually have 13
classes on skillshare yes 13. most of
the online courses I've ever made are on
skillshare where you can access them
completely for free by going to
skillshare.com forward slash Deep dive
and you'll get a one month free trial
anyway on skillshare there are thousands
of classes on all sorts of topics from
entrepreneurship and business to
Lifestyle design to Interior Design to
cooking to graphic design to video
editing loads of stuff but in particular
you might like to check out my own
classes on productivity I have three
classes on skillshare all about
productivity we have the productivity
fundamentals we have productivity
creators and we have productivity
strategies and so if you want to do more
things with your time if you want to do
more of the things that matter to you in
a way that's fun and sustainable you
might like to check out those classes
which again you can check out completely
for free by just going to skillshare.com
deep dive and then once your trial is
over you can choose to carry on with the
subscription I pay for skillshare I
think it's great they've got loads of
classes and so it becomes one of my
first places to go to if I want to teach
myself anything at all so check out my
classes on skillshare and thank you so
much skillshare for sponsoring this
episode
your recent book scorecard marketing
kind of talks about that very tactically
any anything else you'd recommend for
like helping someone learn the skill
so all of these skills relate to a
broader set of skills which is
entrepreneurship and
some of the skills is understanding why
people buy so for example all all people
buy things to relieve a psychological
tension between what they have and what
they want
um so that is the underlying reason why
anyone buys anything there is some form
of a psychological tension something's
not right in the world it should be this
way but it's currently this way and I
want to close that Gap so that's the
buying process now sometimes people
don't have much psychological tension
around something but it could be widened
some people have a dormant psychological
tension which they're not consciously
aware of or they're not solution seeking
they're just dealing they're just
holding on to the problem and holding on
to the frustration but they're not in
the process and you can spark a
decision-making process so the more you
understand why people buy and what's
going on under the surface and the fact
that there are people actively looking
for things and then there are people who
are passively dealing with a
frustrational problem but not actively
searching so getting a working
understanding of these things is really
powerful
the other thing that triggers every
single sale is a combination of emotion
logic and urgency
so
um some and I've found that all
businesses are only really naturally
good at one
so some businesses naturally are good at
generating emotion in their customers
but not logic or urgency some businesses
are really good with the logical side of
what you should buy but they're not very
good at the emotion or the urgency and
some businesses are the hard sales
business they turn the they turn the
screws and they're all about urgency but
they're not very good at logic or
emotion and great businesses they
understand how to do logic emotion and
urgency in the right Doses and they get
the minimum effective dose across nicely
and people go oh I'm excited to buy I
love buying from this company like an
apple would be a great example they give
you logic emotion urgency
um yeah they have the pre-order for the
pre-order and I'm just like oh yeah this
is so good I can prepare my pre-order so
that when 1 pm comes around I can just
hit the button and it's just yeah and
they do a great combination of like
educating you about the phone combined
with showing you stories of people who
are out there taking amazing photos and
they look really cool and it's all woven
in together and then there's a moment to
act so logic emotion urgency all coming
together at once so how do you how do
you learn these skills
well I've written about them you can you
can read over subscribed and scorecard
marketing those are two great books on
that
um so I like you I listen to a lot of
podcasts but there's some other things
you can do you can survey your customers
right so you want to be able to ask lots
of questions about why people are buying
from you or not buying from you you want
to ask people questions where they
quantify as a doctor you probably ask
people on a scale of one to ten how bad
does it hurt
um and people like oh it's a four okay
so it's not as bad as I thought right oh
it's bearable or it's like oh it's a
nine it's like okay well wow that's
pretty intense so asking people to
quantify with a number
is really powerful because that is logic
and emotion coming together so when
people feel something and quantify it
with a number they're integrating their
left and their right brain and they're
giving you very clear signals and
feedback as to what's going on so some
of the questions that are super powerful
to talk to your Market about is on a
scale of one to ten
um how motivate how motivated would you
be to solve this problem on a scale of
one to ten how frustrated are you by
this right because you're looking for
things that people rate highly as a
frustration if it's a dormant need
um uh you know on a scale of one to ten
how happy are you with your existing you
know Solutions so these are the kind of
questions and then you're trying to use
that data to figure out what is the
solution that I can build that really
helps people move from a low score to a
high score on these on these types of
things I know this is getting a little
bit geeky but conducting research of
just 30 people is often very revealing
it tells you a lot about what you are
doing right or not doing right
and yeah some more research is is pretty
powerful one one thing that I used to
have a big hang up about and probably
still do a little bit is that sales and
marketing equals bad
is evil it's like a bit icky it's a bit
scammy and there was a lot of I think
unlearning I had to do when selling our
course for the first time two years ago
now
um and yeah is is this and and it's
definitely a sentiment I've I've heard
from a lot of people that I just I just
hate the idea of sales I hate the idea
of marketing what's what's going on
there I totally agree when you're a
Creator when you when you're building
something and you put your heart and
soul into it the idea that you have to
then justify that and that you have to
convince people to do it it's kind of
like you know weirdly like trying to
sell your best friend to someone or like
you know it's kind of like this weird
thing that you want you want it to be
self-evidently valuable you want to be
able to create something and people self
evidently just know about it and love it
and all of that and that's just not how
humans work right so humans have to go
through a process of discovery and we
have to get to know something which is
all about understanding the logic we
have to get to trust something which is
the emotional connection of like yeah
I've done enough research right and then
we want to basically
um we like it we trust it we feel a
sense that now's the right time so we're
going through this process of discovery
and it doesn't really matter what the
product is whether it be you know camera
equipment or musical equipment or any of
those sorts of things we like to do our
research and we like to go through a
series of steps of getting to know
things so the evidence-based
um research on this is from Professor
Robin Dunbar and from Google
and they say that you go through 11
touch points before you buy something uh
based on your Google search history and
Professor Robin Dunbar says you go
through about seven hours of contact
before you feel a sense of trust so if
you just simply think about what is
marketing there to do it's there to
accelerate that Journey at scale with
more people to help guide them through a
process of discovery so that they get to
know about something like it trust it
learn about it all right re you know
you're helping them to discover and
research it unfortunately there is a
part of every sale that is urgency and
this is the ickiest part that most
people hate which is trying to tell
people that now's the right time to buy
something
so
we I don't think many people have a
problem with communicating the emotional
payoff of their product that it's going
to feel great and that it's going to be
a really enjoyable thing I don't think
people have much of a problem talking
about the logic sometimes they do
because logic is about quantifying and
return on investment and this is where
this is the cost to benefit analysis
right it's this is why you would do it
but then what people want to do is they
want to be able to say okay when you're
ready come and come back and buy yeah
space even to humans what do they do
they forget and they go find something
else and all of that so we need an
urgency trigger urgency is a little bit
like a spice than an ingredient you
don't want to overuse it but there needs
to be a subtext of urgency
now for most products the only viable
subtext of urgency that works is
genuinely being oversubscribed
so genuinely being oversubscribed means
that there are plenty of people who want
this there is genuinely a limited number
available or there's a start date
there's a reason that you need to begin
and unfortunately it's only going to be
available for this number of people now
what the perfect scenario is is that
there's some form of demand and Supply
tension that's transparent yep so for
example if there's a lineup out the
front of the restaurant oh it must be a
good restaurant and you must need to
book ahead
um if there is
um you know if Apple phones sell out in
the first week and then you have to wait
and it's a delay oh okay so if I don't
buy then I'm gonna have to be the person
who gets it three months from now so the
subtext of demand and Supply tension and
some form of transparency that we can
see that transparency transparently
there's a lot of people who want this
there's only a limited number or there's
a start time yeah uh okay I better do
this yeah
yeah with my with my first business when
I was 19 and selling courses to help
people get into med school uh we did and
I I I'm not sure how ethical this was
but we would uh artificially sell out
or like a deliberately book smaller
venues for places that we knew like
wouldn't have that much demand and so
when we sold seven seats it's like sold
out and no one has to know it was only
sold out of seven but they're just sold
out in LA and some CSS stuff to make it
look red and like um
and that seemed to just work but yeah
here's the here's the frustrating thing
about humans the frustrating thing is
that taking no action is actually quite
safe and you can't most people kind of
have a subconscious belief that if I
don't take action then nothing really
bad can go wrong but if I do take action
then
um you know something might go wrong so
it's unfortunate but there is no really
there's no successful businesses that
are long-term successful that don't do
something around creating an urgency
queue uh for for buying right and if
they do if they don't do logic emotion
and urgency they're normally not
profitable so you get a lot of
businesses that they turn over money but
they're not very profitable Airlines for
example
so can you imagine if if there was such
thing as a prophet God who handed that
Prophet fairly and they looked at every
business model and they said only the
business models that are really hard to
operate and really important to society
those will get the profit and anyone
who's just Superfluous you know you
don't get any profit so you look at the
airline industry and you say you've got
to have 100 safety hugely Capital
intensive customer service expectations
are through the roof Logistics you've
got to leave on time finish on like land
on time if you're a minute late we're
going to start charging you a fee a
penalty and you think wow what an
incredibly complex business model
I bet the prophet Gods would give them
50 profit margins it's like no no it's
like five to ten percent profit margins
it's nothing why simply because there's
freely available there's no there's
always seats available you can buy a
ticket when you want if you missed this
one there'll be another one going in an
hour right so all of that's built into
it
let's have a look at the opposite the
opposite is Rolex
all right so Rolex is a business that
has barely innovated its product in many
years a Rolex today looks much the same
as Rolex 50 years ago it's made from the
same materials uh it's made pretty much
in the same way in the same place so
there's hardly any Innovation uh you
they're terrible at customer service
um the product itself can be easily
copied
um a copy can cost one tenth to one
twentieth of of an actual real article
but here's the difference Rolex has a
waiting list of 18 months to get a
genuine Rolex and when they call you
they say uh we've got your watch
available but we can only hold it for
you for three days
um if not you'll miss out on it and
you'll go back on the waiting list for
18 months
um now Rolex is massively profitable
something like 70 margins so you know
this is this is the difference between
being over subscribed Lodge commotion
urgency
um actually and I will say this Rolex
has logic emotion and urgency the
emotion is status and achievement and
significance and uh marking in a
significant occasion the logic is that
they hold their value they're incredibly
good hedge against inflation there are
people who buy Rolexes and keep them in
a draw purely as a store of wealth
and the urgency is that there's a 19
month waiting list so when you bring it
all together explosive
nice
okay so the mentor John
um these three big lessons the value of
money
um no news is good and um everything is
Downstream of lead generation
so what what happened next in your story
so you're 24 you're doing 10 million a
year in this company you've got you've
got a team of 20 people you're doing
marketing for for other businesses yeah
so we were pretty concentrated with one
major client I had a big falling out
with that client they were going to
acquire us
um and then they did a really nasty
negotiation tactic
um
and I threw my toys out the pram and
basically said deals off I'm moving to
London I'm going to go do something else
oh um okay yeah because I was 24 25. I
mean it's funny because I walked away
from from tens of millions in that sale
um and they had disrespected me and
tried to bully in the situation not
expecting like because they're they're
more grown up
they would never walk away from millions
and minions but everything had come to
me so easily and so quickly that I just
had a very different attitude and
my business partner and I just went we
don't want to work with these guys long
term if this is how they are in the
negotiation then this is going to be
horrible
um
let's turn it off and they were shocked
and then they tried to sue us
um okay yeah they were like really it
was really weird it was very weird but
anyway we we untangled ourselves from
that
um and then I was offered the
opportunity to go launch an office in
London of that business and take it to
London and it was just kind of like you
know what this will be really fun uh
there's three times as many people in
the UK and we're gonna just you know
travel and we'll go to Europe and we'll
go snowboarding and we'll you know we'll
go to Ibiza and we'll you know do all
that stuff so we just kind of went oh
that's it we're going to move to London
okay so it was a really random we went
from having tens of millions to to
basically shutting down the Australian
business and moving to London why did
you shut it down why not keep it going
because original manager all this as a
24 year old okay fine it was just it was
just the next adventure so we jumped you
know we'd ended the relationship with a
major client who represented a huge
chunk of Revenue and we could either
restart in Australia with a new class or
restart in London it just felt like a
great time to go restart in London okay
so question on this front so at this
point you're 24 you've presumably got a
net worth that's in the six or seven
figures uh probably seven and you could
you could just choose to put your feet
up and not work and and stuff probably
live the the good life in Bali or
whatever that looks like
um what gave you that drive for a kind
of more more ambition more
stuff
um it was hugely fun you've got to
remember we were working and partying
and traveling and like like the business
was not digging ditches we were running
events going to restaurants going to
nightclubs
um driving fancy cars
um all of my mentors were way ahead of
me
um you know I was hanging around with
people who had businesses doing 50
million 100 million
um I was regularly hanging out with
people who had built billion dollar
businesses and things like that because
we would hire speakers and we'd have
people like dragons and sharks and um
best-selling authors and people who'd
written you know amazing books and all
this so I was hanging around a peer
group of people who normalized that
level of life
um and I was being invited as this young
entrepreneur into these really great
amazing circles and you know I got paid
to go to Bali and speak at a conference
and I got paid to hang out backstage
with all the people so why would I give
that up that I mean okay and it was also
everyone on the team was under 30 and we
were all single and we were all like
nightclubby kind of people so we were
all like a typical week we'd finish up
the week and then we'd all go clubbing
um as a team nice cool so you're so you
moved to London and you were like 25 for
this point like 24 25. uh yeah about 25
yeah okay so what was that what well we
launched the launched a similar business
in London um working with
um uh International speakers to launch
them in the UK Market
um took off crazy four million pounds in
the first year
um and just doing the event stuff yeah
event staff and all this sort of lead
gen stuff basically doing launches for
businesses that were successful outside
of the UK yeah so we had a Singaporean
company and we had a US company and we
were launching them in in the uh in the
UK uh four million in year one and
um at the end of year one we hired the
London Palladium Theater 2000 seats
um and we like did 600 Grand worth of
sales in the following week it was just
wild right so it was good times and then
the GFC came along Global financial
crisis and the whole thing came crashing
down so we went from making millions
down to 400 000 in 2009 so it was like
just a complete like the recession just
put a shop and stop to everything
um our Singaporean client
uh almost collapsed in Asia and had to
stop coming to the UK right because that
was their growth plan so that client was
gone and then our U.S client that pound
against the um dollar went from like two
to one to like it jumped by like 40 in a
day and it was just like unaffordable to
do the deal so it just wasn't the
exchange rate didn't work
um and we weren't able to successfully
renegotiate
so I went from living in a penthouse
apartment near Chelsea
to moving into my sister's spare room in
Acton and
um like just entering like a really
weird dark time of like oh my goodness
everything is just literally come
crashing without how how was that
transition no it was great yeah
fantastic I recommend it to everyone it
was dark and horrible it was so dark and
horrible I remember in the middle of
winter slipping on ice and like almost
breaking my arm and
um and I remember a really bad phone
call
and hanging up and being on a like on a
reflex of just like anger
pretty much fist out like that and
banging it into a wall a concrete wall
and like almost breaking my hand and I
almost had a almost broken hand and
almost broken arm and I'm like what is
going on
um and yeah it was a horrible time
um and it was a bit it was a time of
reflection and there was time of
thinking through what do I want to do
next and the other weird thing that
happened at that time is I decided to
try and sell the business and uh I had
this guy who agreed to buy the business
for 300 Grand to two payments of 150
Grand and I was like oh you know at
least I'll start again with something
new but I'll have 300 Grand and anyway
on the day of exchange
um he just doesn't show up and turns out
he had a heart attack and went into
hospital and brand new oh my goodness
randomly my acquire yeah I had had a
heart attack
um yeah so weird like crazy weird time
um how long did that period last
so in 2009 I wrote the book key person
of influence which was all about my
experience working with celebrities and
authors and how they were building
personal Brands during my reflection
period i reflected on what am I really
excited about social media
um this new emerging technology called
Facebook and YouTube and Twitter and all
this sort of stuff and how how we've
built these technological engines to
build personal Brands and how that will
give rise to new types of businesses and
all this sort of stuff so 2010 I
launched something called the key person
of influence accelerator it's a huge
success we launch in London it sells out
three times in a row we launch in
Melbourne we launch in Sydney we launch
in Singapore we launched in Tampa
Florida we're launching Canada so
suddenly I'm building a Global business
again and we're back to like eight
cities a million per City you know so
we're just smashing smashing it um so it
was a then it was another
uh that was over the following couple of
years oh wow okay so the key key person
of influence the five-step method to
become one of the most highly valued and
highly paid people in your industry I
would love to come to this in a moment
um but I guess sort of you wrote
entrepreneurial Revolution a few years
later and this is sort of the more more
like getting started with
entrepreneurship be type book so when I
was writing key person of influence
there was about 8 000 words at the
beginning setting the scene for the
strange times that we're in and that the
world is changing in a massive way and
it just seemed like the book took
forever to kick off and get going so I
cut that 8 000 words off and I parked it
and then I released kpi and it became a
big it became a good bestseller and then
the publisher said well what do you want
to do next do you want to do another
book and say oh I've got this 8 000
words that I cut out and I sent that
across and they went oh that's a book
that's a great book it's all about how
to start up as an entrepreneur before
you're a key person of influence yeah
and I'm like oh okay so I released
entrepreneur Revolution so what is what
is the entrepreneurial Revolution so
this is the idea and a lot of your
listeners won't get the significance of
this but
you know I was born in 1981 and I was
born in the Industrial Age of you know
very much career and Workforce and all
this there was no such thing as being a
Creator and there was no Creator economy
and there was there was no just become a
YouTuber
you know of course none of that existed
um and then
there's this whole other world that we
live in now where people can live and
work from anywhere you can set up a
business you can have a thousand dollars
startup costs and you know start a
business that's Global you could
literally use your phone and build a
business that impacts thousands of lives
and it's like wow what a time to be
alive
um what an incredible moment in time
that for the first time ever
so I likened this as an analogy to what
it must have been like going from the
agricultural age where everyone had to
have a farm and you had to have a family
farm and you had to plow a field by hand
or with the donkey and then suddenly
tractors and then suddenly factories and
then now there's this entire different
economy that exists with its own set of
rules completely different rules and I
used this analogy of like you know what
must it have been like to look across to
the neighboring Factory and see a 22
year old on a tractor doing the work of
100 people
and now we look at what well there's a
22 year old with a tick tock account
making three million dollars or whatever
and it's like whoa but how's that
happening well they're they're playing a
different game and there's this digital
age there's this entrepreneur Revolution
so the book outlines the times that
we're in and then it says okay
given that the world has changed and
that there's a new set of rules but most
of us were raised in a schooling system
that was built for Industrial Age what
are the new rules how do we leverage the
new rules how do we start something that
is in alignment with the new rules right
and how do we then build a successful
business and launch a successful
business with a different mindset
uh yeah that's
I was just thinking that
um the
the industrial revolutionary type
mindset I think is
still very prevalent amongst
probably like most people that I know
like every anyone who's not an
entrepreneur or Creator yeah like half
of my friends are medics and so that's
still a very much a you have a job you
go to it like and there's no innovation
it's a system that shouldn't change
radically right because or should change
slowly yeah exactly because you're
dealing with People's Health outcomes so
it's Gonna Change really slowly and the
school system is a really slow changing
system as well so ultimately we have a
health system and we have a school
system that is very much entrenched in
the Industrial Age yeah and I think also
that and and so like often
it's it's like when I was first doing
doing the YouTube stuff and even even
with my first business when I was at
University which was you know was I was
making like I don't know 40K or 50k or
something which was the equivalent of a
doctor's salary when I was like in in
med school my mind was just like blowing
a stat how sort of like easy it was to
to make that money compared to toiling
away on award for 60 hours a week yeah
and then when I actually started working
and I was toiling away on a water 60
hours a week and all of a sudden like
one 30 second YouTube integration where
I just spoke to the camera about a
freaking app was making the equivalent
of one month salary it just completely
changed my entire world but just totally
it's like you're on the tractor plowing
the field in a day yeah or you're one of
a hundred people with a hand plow going
this is ridiculous and it's this weird
thing of like well why would I not do it
it's hard not to exactly so there's some
things that you'll notice in the
Industrial Age so for example we teach
kids that you should not be disruptive
right the worst thing you can get on
your report card is you know Ali is a
disruptive person in the classroom the
best thing they can possibly call you on
the front cover of Inc magazine is
disruptive right so you know there's a
disconnect between these things in
school putting together a team of smart
kids who give you the answers is called
cheating in life that's called having an
executive team that is a really high
functioning executive team so if I for
me personally if I have a great CFO who
does all my maths homework for me that's
smart that's a good thing to have but in
school that would be the worst thing to
do
um so you know we're now this and I
mentioned it before component labor is
the name of the game in the schooling
system your job is to become a useful
component of Labor to someone's big
machine and we're not taught anything
about you know sales marketing money
management uh coming up with ideas
ideation minimum viable product testing
you know Market surveys none of that
stuff is in school yeah I I think the
school thing as well also encourages the
sort of perfectionistic attitude of I'm
going to do the work and then I'm going
to hand it in and I'm going to get a
grade for the thing and I'm now now my
self-worth is wedded to the grade
um and so like again if I just think of
the the
um the example of a bunch of my friends
who did really really well in school and
they are doing well in their corporate
jobs or something
to put out a single blog post or write a
single thing on LinkedIn to them feels
like oh my God it has to be perfect and
it's just this attitude of like I can't
put something else someone has to
approve it yeah someone has to approve
it yeah yeah and even almost
a kind of kind of maybe an unhealthy
obsession with qualifications yeah
um I randomly met a doctor at the train
station who recognized me you know like
last week sometime and she had been in
medicine for 14 years and was come
across my staff I think she actually
read some of your books as well and was
sort of transitioning out to become a
coach which was doing a coaching
coaching qualification yeah and then we
grabbed breakfast and she was like I I
was like okay so how's the coaching
business going and she was like oh you
know I'm I'm doing it for free for a few
friends and I was like okay what's
stopping you from charging and she was
like oh well I haven't finished my
qualification yet like oh it's gonna
happen in like four months I was like
okay and then when that happens what are
you gonna do next and he was like oh
then I'll start posting on Facebook and
I was like when are you going to charge
people for the coaching she was like oh
you know maybe in a year or two yeah
when I get a letter from someone yeah
yeah now it's time to charge I have a
doctor friend who told me oh I'm
thinking of starting a business and then
next time I saw him he'd enrolled in an
MBA
um for the certification uh but I mean
imagine if in school they said it's
actually the first person to hand in
their assignment and it only has to be
directionally correct
like then it would be a very different
environment it's like we're going to
Mark you based on speed to Market like
here's the assignment
clock starts now whoever can hand in
something that meets minimum standards
and is directionally correct you're the
one who does it and and extra points if
you can pull together three or four
people who all work together and you you
can you can get something there
yeah yeah I think on on this point as
well like I I've had similar
conversations with friends and
um there seems to be a lot of resistance
in the sense of oh but are you saying
that a neurosurgeon doesn't need to be
qualified
yeah no definitely if your component
labor you have to be certified you have
to because you're a component you're Cog
in the machine and that Cog has to be
perfectly fit for the machine
um so you know you absolutely have to be
there are certain professions especially
like medicine that you've got to be
qualified in and uh yeah perfect
perfectly machined within an inch but I
guess the danger is that sort of having
that way of thinking which then yeah
bleeds into anything else and you think
that suddenly someone has to give you
permission to do a thing as soon as
you're in the entrepreneur Evolution
you're adopting a very different mindset
it's a mindset of not knowing rather
than knowing so the most curious person
wins not the most qualified person so if
you said oh I'm going through a period
of great curiosity I know nothing and
I'm trying to explore what people are
frustrated by that's probably the
smarter position to take as an
entrepreneur some of the best
entrepreneurs they love saying things
like talk to me like I'm a
three-year-old I just don't understand
sometimes they deeply understand but
they'll ask dumb questions because
they're trying to be they're trying to
stay curious uh Steve Jobs advice in his
uh commencement speech was stay humble
stay curious
yeah that just bugs I thought so again
when when I was at University I'm kind
of building this business and and stuff
um I would
it was weird how often I'd be the one to
put my hand up in a lecture and ask a
question about something that was like
apparently obvious but like I I just had
this sort of complete non-fair of
looking like an idiot and a bunch of
friends spoke to me afterwards and even
to this day I think I think it was like
two weeks ago I was I was chatting to
some friends and they were like yeah I
remember you would always ask these like
dumb questions and lectures and I'd be
thinking the same thing but I would be
thinking I don't ask the question
because I don't want to look dumb I was
like well it and it was I think having
done the entrepreneur thing and trying
to do what make my web design business
when I was 14 years old all like sort of
in entrenched in me this idea that like
it's totally reasonable to ask a dumb
question yeah if you're a component
if you're a cog in the machine you don't
want to reveal that there might be a
crack in the Cog right because then they
might replace you so it's better to be
quiet and pretend that you're a
perfectly formed Cog as opposed to but
if you're building the machine and
you're looking for how could this
machine run better how could this be
optimized to produce better outcomes
then you're totally looking for you know
how you're basically going back to First
principles you're like well what problem
are we trying to solve what are we
solving for how do we do that faster
what's the fastest point between point a
and point B talk to me like I'm an idiot
right so those sorts of things
um become very useful and that's the big
mindset shift so in the book
entrepreneur Revolution it's all about
changing the mindset it's about getting
out of the traditional mindset I talk
about three mindsets reptile which is
fight flight freeze anger aggression
upset emotional response there's
autopilot which is learn repeat learn
repeat
um you know repeat the past repeat the
past uh put more inputs in remember
those inputs then deliver the correct
outputs and then there's Visionary
strategic thinking
um inspiration love connection empathy
uh curiosity all of those sorts of
things so it's about being in that
Visionary mind more than the autopilot
or the reptile nice
nice okay so let's say someone is
listening to this or watching this and
they've got a normal job uh let's say I
don't know they're working consulting or
something like that and they're like
cool I love the idea of being an
entrepreneur I did my con I joined my
consulting job because
quote it would teach skills that I could
then use to start a startup someday but
they've ended up there for way too long
because the promotion cycle is or the
bonus cycle is always yeah it's you know
it's only four months away
um what would be the sort of next steps
that someone would take to kind of
develop this mindset slash become an
entrepreneur well you can develop the
mindset by having a go at producing
something of value
um there's a there's a few sets of steps
that you want to go through so one step
is ideation ideation is coming up with
at least 10 ideas and then figuring out
which one would be the best or the which
two or three ideas would be the best so
that's an actual process called ideation
and most people jump from first idea to
action rather than coming up with nine
other ideas and saying well why did I
choose that one and you know when I
worked with one of our our guys who was
a billionaire I said how do you create a
billion dollar company he's like oh it's
easy you come up with 10 ideas that
could be billion dollar companies and
then start narrowing it down and then
so it's like oh okay uh fair enough yeah
so he said well it's either going to be
a telecommunications company or it's
going to be a technical company or it's
going to be a bank or it's you know so
he's like there's only a few things yeah
he's like there's only a few things a
billion dollar company could be so
you've got to then figure out which one
would it be uh like what would be your
take on it because so we went through
and and he was the first one to show me
just this first step of ideation so you
want to go through ideation and come up
with a bit of a criteria
as I said by the way joining an
entrepreneurial team is is better than
trying to start one yourself so I'm a
big fan of let's say I'm jumping around
here I apologize but let's say you are a
consultant for a large company go be a
consultant for a 10 person company go be
a consultant for a five-person boutique
and do that for a year or two
um and you're gonna be the special
person because you came from a big name
brand and now you're working in a
boutique they're going to treat you like
a king yeah right or a queen so it's
going to be great okay just on that note
um I don't forget your take on this one
issue that a lot of people have is
um I am currently making X at my current
company big company etc etc I would be
taking a pay cut to do this other thing
that sounds cool
and it's I I think it's interesting
because usually X is like higher than
what you would actually need to live and
usually the new salary is also a very
reasonable salary but people I think
feel like oh I I don't want to take a
drop in my paid yeah yeah and I can
understand that especially look you're
in a unique position in the sense that
you don't have kids if once you've got
kids then as much as you might
personally like for me personally right
I can personally happily live mattress
on the floor
um you know ramen noodles whatever right
that wouldn't bother me at all
um but now I have kids we have huge
overheads insane overheads every month
right and
um and I can't make decisions of like oh
yeah we'll all just live on mattresses
on the floor
um I might find myself divorced or
something like that so
um so the you know the the key thing or
it wouldn't be fair to take them into
that decision so the key thing is there
are certain people who can't take a pay
cut you've got to figure it out so
you've got to figure out okay what is my
after tax earnings and sometimes a pay
cut is not as Savage as you think about
it if it's after tax
um you also might be spending a lot of
money on commuting or you might be
spending a lot of money on things to
keep up that particular role which may
not come with a boutique role
okay you also might have a boutique plus
your uh side hustle Venture money as a
bit of a Crossfade or you might view it
as making an investment so let's say
you're taking a 10 grand pay cut you're
actually the framing of it is I'm
actually investing 10 grand into the
creation of a startup I'm willing to
invest up to 30 000 so I'm willing to
take this pay cut for three years as an
investment into the equity that I own in
my own business so it's not a pay cut
it's an investment into the startup
Equity you know so it's a bit of a
mental mental gymnastics to justify
activity but uh you know but essentially
that's what you are doing you you are
making an investment into startup equity
so
um yeah it is tricky it is difficult um
one of the things that I recommend is
you could do a little bit of
um evening consulting or something like
that uh there have been times for me
personally where I have taken on a
client in La being in London because I
wanted to earn an extra amount of money
and being in London allows me to consult
in La at 8 30 PM till 10 pm
right so I can do a Consulting gig and
do it in my evening in the morning so
you know there are things that we live
in this incredible range of options
right now yeah just on that note so we
we were kind of talking about steps
steps to take me and when we said maybe
joining an entrepreneurial company might
be a good a good sort of springboard um
one thing that a lot of people talk
about in who who've had like success in
business is how in the early days it was
it was quite a lot quite a long slog
quite a grindy like uh or like even
though it was fun like work-life balance
wasn't quite there and usually when
people get older by the time I speak to
them on the podcast they're a bit more
like work-life valency and chill and
stuff yeah and I'm always intrigued like
does uh to what extent is it reasonable
to want to have slash have work-life
balance while you're starting something
versus once it's already successful and
now you can chill so it's quite a luxury
belief the idea of having work-life
balance it's something that well it's
something it's something that you can
afford to have if you've made so once
you hit a certain level of wealth um and
success you can afford to pontificate
about work-life balance
um and you know if you're a single
person who doesn't have any dependence
you can afford to think about work-life
balance
um
the the numbers the statistics are very
very clear that the vast majority of
people who earn a lot of money who make
a breakthrough in business have a period
of being well out of balance I mean
there is not anyone who's winning an
Olympic medal who's not crazy focused on
that goal there's not anyone who is
developing a high-rise building that
isn't you know focused on that goal so
especially when you're creating a
breakthrough and especially if it's an
outstanding result
the data doesn't lie about this it's
it's for something like 65 of all people
earning over 100 Grand to 55 hours a
week or more so you know and when you
look at almost all entrepreneurs here's
here's the reality of business
you're when you're starting a business
you're in the process of creating an
asset
sweating that asset and keeping track of
the what's going on you're doing
strategy operations sales and marketing
Finance
HR you're hiring people onboarding
people so let's be real about it if you
are super optimized and gave each of
those four things
15 hours a week they're 60 hours
you know and that's if you're doing
part-time on each of those like 15 hours
a week is part-time sales you know 15
hours a week is part-time creating an
asset so when you get to work-life
balances when you have a team if you
have eight people working on a team
and you take a holiday seven out of
eight are still working on the business
so it works uh if you've got eight
people on a team and
um you know you come up with an idea
you've got a group of people who can
refine that idea Implement that idea
work on that idea and produce something
and you've probably got someone who's
full-time sales and you've probably got
someone who's full-time marketing so now
you've got a bit of Team Dynamic team
play one of the great things to come out
of the Industrial Age was something
called a division of labor which is that
if people just focus on one job and
don't jump around they make a lot more
stuff and that's true for any
entrepreneurial business a sales person
who's just focused on sales gets good at
sales and someone who's focused on
editing videos gets good at editing
videos so if you try and get the video
editor to make sales they're going to
suck at both
so
um work-life balance does tend to come
later I know that's unpopular to say
everyone wants to be like oh no peace
love of Hare Krishna as we can all just
you know have a multi-million pound
business in our spare time but everyone
I know who's gone through that even the
people who talk about work-life balance
the way they came to work-life balance
as a concept was by getting themselves
completely burnt out
um you know and then they well I'm
reformed okay great you're reformed nice
of you now you're a millionaire to be so
reformed right now you've got 55 people
on your team working behind the scenes
yeah fabulous now you can just do a
strategic role well well done that's the
end state but what they're not being
honest about is how they got there and
they got there normally by being out of
balance they said no to a lot of stuff
um you know they didn't go to the
parties they
um you know like for example when I did
the 10 million year that like all of
those five years working for John and
then that that was 60 hours a week every
week
um we worked weekends we ran events on
the weekend uh we might have had one
weekend offer in a month we like when I
was starting my first business it was
roll out of bed have breakfast and as
soon as I finished breakfast it's start
work and then it's work work work work
work until dinner time and then finish
dinner and then maybe do some more stuff
after dinner and then go to bed and that
was every day and now we were doing fun
stuff as well taking clients out to
restaurants going out partying and all
of that sort of stuff there's no way I
could have built those businesses
without putting in serious time
yeah building an asset making sales the
whole lot the whole thing in your
experience like having having spoken to
a bunch of people who are successful in
business
do many of them regret the way that they
spent their youth in Hustle mode or is
it a lot of it was like oh I'm glad I'm
chilled out now but I kind of had to get
through that phase and I don't regret
putting in all that work back when I was
young uh well for starters let's be
let's go to the data as well
um most people who start a business are
42 most successful entrepreneurs are 42
and they start
um so most the the most well-worn path
is that you work for someone in your 20s
and you do an apprenticeship in your 30s
you start to get your stride and you
start to make some inroads and you start
to demonstrate value you work up up the
chain a little bit
towards your late 30s early 40s you
start to figure out how this whole
industry works and you've got contacts
connections you're trusted and then at
42 you start a business that you then
sell at 57 15 years later and make your
minions so that's the data that's the
path right so the path that most people
take is career
and this is most successful Entre
millionaire entrepreneurs started at 42
sold the business at 57.
um so regretting the there are very few
who actually super successful
entrepreneurs who started in their 20s
um I've not met many people who do
regret that
um I think a lot of people went oh my
goodness thank goodness I I jumped in
with both feet when I had that when I
didn't have the commitments because life
gets more complicated not less
complicated you know we end up you know
we end up with houses and families and
uh you know teams and uh all the stuff
we end up with sick parents we end up
with uh diseases or ailments
um all of that stuff that's what that's
life right the least complex is age 20.
yeah
so there's a
this has a friend of mine who's sort of
she's she's currently working full-time
as a doctor and like wants to do uh sort
of create a thing on the side and has
kind of dabbled with it a little bit and
has recognized that hey doing doing the
side hustle on top of the full-time job
is incompatible with also having a
social life and also doing hobbies and
also self-care and also going to the gym
every day and also doing like yeah
having good sort of having eight hours
of sleep a night
and I'm just like yeah it is
um and you kind of have to choose if you
want it and whether whether it's worth
the payoff and like how how would you
think about it it's a huge risk
um there are very few broke struggling
doctors right doctors cluster around a
high point in society around probably
the top 10 percent of earners
um and it's very unlikely that you would
meet someone who describes himself as a
Doctor Who's just trying to get a break
and trying to make it and you know yeah
they're usually pretty middle class
pretty chill yeah there's hardly any
that are crazy like billionaires and
there's hardly any that actually drop
below 35 000 a year or something like
that so you've you've you've got a very
safe path a safe path would mean the
data clusters around a particular
outcome and all the data sets around
that outcome right so that is the
doctor's path the doctor's path is very
safely you're going to end up in this
good comfortable lifestyle that's not
true for entrepreneurship there are
billionaires and there are loads of
people who are completely broken
struggling there are people who plowed
their life savings in
um you know and and they're you know it
was the worst decision they ever made
they just weren't cut out for it or
they've made they made radical decision
so
um she's right to
not take that lightly that's a that's an
important decision to make uh you need
to really get
good signals from the market that the
market wants this thing that you have so
once again wanting to have a side hustle
wanting to have this is all about your
own personal needs which are irrelevant
to the market the market does not care
right like if I go and buy a kebab at
three o'clock in the morning
do I ever ask the Kebab shop owner are
you okay are you managing your work-life
balance enough why are you out here at
three o'clock in the morning you know is
your family seeing enough of you I'm not
asking anything like that I'm just
paying my four pounds for my Kebab at
three o'clock in the morning I have no
cat the market does not care about your
work-life balance doesn't care about how
healthy or happy you are it just cares
whether you're meeting its needs so the
starting point for any business first
principles is not what do you want it's
like does the market want something and
are you are you willing and able to to
make that work for the marketplace but
you can't be too self-centered here your
entrepreneurship is an active service it
is a it is a gift to the world you're
creating something that's going to solve
problems for others in a scalable way
you're going to create jobs for others
all the hard as you get bigger and
bigger
all the hard problems are going to roll
up to your entrepreneurial desk all the
easy stuff will be solved by the people
that you hire and only the tricky stuff
gets to you
um so you've got to work out
have I got a sufficient number of
signals from Market that the market says
I need you to I need you to do this you
didn't quit your medical career until
you were getting people signing up and
subscribing and there were good solid
signals where your brain very logically
and mathematically worked out I don't
know I can I can do this I'm getting a
signal from Market but there are many
people who might go oh it he just jumped
out I don't think that's the case yeah
it was three years of like Market making
and then of getting the signals to be
like okay now it's time totally yeah
exactly so I'd encourage people to that
now you don't have to take three years
to get the signals you could do 30 to
150 surveys and people say 100 I really
want this thing I want that CrossFit gym
in Putney to exist yeah and you know we
need you to set that up great and then I
would also encourage once again go do a
year or two with an existing business
um you know a boutique go work for an
entrepreneur see if you actually like
the like the lifestyle yeah
yeah I love it it's just like a a fairly
reasonable path of like hey this is like
the the entrepreneur game is a different
kind of game it's got different kind of
rules so understand what the rules are
recognize that your outcomes may vary
massively compared to the safe career
that you're in where outcomes cluster
about a specific specific area
and now given that we know that there is
there is a quick risky bet to make here
let's try and figure out a way to
de-risk the BET and signals from the
market are one way of doing that
um and I guess even when someone has a
full-time job especially has a full-time
job the ideation stage that we've talked
about coming up with 10 1500 ideas for
what could work and narrowing them down
and then figuring out ways to test those
without spending money that is the next
step called MVP
minimum viable product so minimum viable
product is one of the best things you
can do is set up either a scorecard or
an event and see if you can fill an
event or get a scorecard so let's say
you want to set up a health related
business because you're a doctor and you
want to zero in on a particular health
related set of products can you get 30
or 40 people to turn up to an event on
that topic
um you might discover it's a lot of work
just to get 30 people to show up to an
event and you might discover you push
the door and it flings right open you
book a venue for 30 and you know 70s
show up and it's like oh okay that's a
pretty cool signal a scorecard is where
you essentially set up an online survey
or question where people can Benchmark
themselves and that is an amazing MVP
minimum viable product so you're
essentially collecting data you're
collecting signals of interest and
you're getting people to reveal
themselves as being interested in that
topic so you might say oh what I want to
do is I want to be a marathon running
coach I'm going to help people run
marathons right
he said okay great I'm going to launch
the are you ready to run a marathon
scorecard and we're going to see if I
can get people to take that for free
if I can't get people to take that for
free there's no way I'm going to get
them to pay because everything's
Downstream from lead generation yeah so
if I can't generate the leads forget
about the business yeah and it's like
okay what's my next idea oh my next idea
is Diet coach I'm going to help people
to eat better okay
um are you ready to improve your diet
take the scorecard um is your diet
optimized take the scorecard uh okay
nice great I'll answer the quiz okay oh
look I've got 150 people who answered
this and look all of them struggle with
this thing and I guess you can just
start by making one of these things on
like some free software and chucking on
your Facebook friends list or messaging
your friends on Instagram who you know
someone created that software yeah yeah
so what is a what is the scorecard
what's the deal with that so when I
launched the key person of influence
accelerator we created the key person of
influence scorecard and this became a
massive thing 90 000 people took it and
we made 15 million pounds off the back
end of sales and it's just like a
glorified online quiz it's a glorified
online quiz right it's like a
personality test test it essentially in
the book it says are you any good at
pitching are you any good at creating
products and it asks the scorecard asks
you a series of questions and it gives
you a score yeah and it says you're a
four out of ten for people something so
addictive about that I signed up with a
CEO coach like three or three days ago
he had two scorecards that he made me
take and I was like damn I've got a lot
of improvement yeah right because it's
like if I ask you 50 questions and each
question gives you a little bit of
psychological
um you know tension and you're like and
then it adds up and then your score
comes out at 43 yeah you being you
you're like oh god I've got to optimize
right up there's so much to improve
isn't that great exactly so that
quantification
um on a scale of one to ten how painful
is it oh it's a four out of ten right so
the all of this works psychologically it
all comes together in a scorecard so
basically we launched a scorecard key
person of influence it was a huge
success you know lots of millions and
millions worth of sales came off the
back of it and my client started saying
hey that assessment thing that I told or
how do I get one of those for my
business so at the time I had an I.T
business and we were building them for
clients about eight grand each and we're
basically my now co-founder Steve he was
building them I was selling them and we
sold like 10 uh and everyone who bought
one had a massive result so we had this
guy who was running a DJ School
he had this big social media following
and then he launched the DJ scorecard
are you ready to become a professional
DJ we're going to measure you on five
areas and suddenly thousands of people
are taking the scorecard and he's got
all this data and he's like whoa and his
business grew big off the back so went
from having a social media following to
having proprietary data and leads so we
saw this working we thought okay let's
make it super easy and not eight grand
we created score app
um now people can just basically build
their own scorecards it gives you a
template with a landing page and a quick
questionnaire and a results page and a
PDF and then you create your own
scorecards so like for example you could
do a productivity scorecard yeah I was
just thinking about I was like well I
don't have a productivity scorecard yeah
that'll be so good yeah I'd basically
take all my knowledge of productivity
and be like do you currently have uh
sort of Life values do you currently do
a weekly review do you currently set a
daily highlight every morning and the
answer was a lot of those things will if
the answer to all those things is yes
it's like I have nothing to teach you
but like for 99.9 of people there will
be holding on that thing and I can be
like all right cool here are the
resources and you don't have to waste
time on the things that you're good at
you can just go straight to oh okay all
of your productivity issues relates to
scheduling yeah so let's get you all the
scheduling tools so that and that's your
own proprietary data at the moment I
it's unlikely but at the moment social
media could just switch you off they
have done that with people um I can't
imagine you getting Switched Off with
with your radicals
yeah uh but but the good thing about
this is you would own your own database
yeah you'd have your own data damn
because we do so much work and we're
creating courses and stuff and we will
whip together a landing page and
sometimes do a little bit of
pre-collecting things and then I read
over subscribe like oh we should
probably do a little bit more it we
probably shouldn't just be like all
right here's the thing guys take it or
leave it we're like there's more to do
and a scorecard just feels like it's
just like we just take our core syllabus
and turn it into questions and then yeah
people identify that okay my camera
confidence is at 15 I have so much to go
this course will take me up to 95. yeah
yeah and then they take the scorecard at
the end and they go it did take me to
95. yeah and if it doesn't we can give
them give them their money back yeah
that's like a guarantee tied to the
thing exactly and it quantifies it and
it makes it Roi is clear the other thing
too is you might have lots of ideas and
you might say oh okay creating a whole
course is going to take three weeks
agency yeah it does way more than three
weeks so let's say you say okay well
I've got three ideas and I'm not sure
which one yeah I'll just take three
scorecard I'll create three score cards
yes I have an idea for a course of like
um
essentially called something like the
life-changing magic of a personal
assistant yeah and the team has always
been a bit like I don't know if anyone
should you hire a personal assistant
take the scorecard yeah so then yeah
this is so good there's four thousand
people take the scorecard it's like we
should clearly make a course on this yes
and then we can then we've got their
email addresses we can interview them we
can be like hey what are your problems
like let's make sure this course you'll
know the question you'll know what their
problems are because they'll have
answered the questions this is genius
okay cool anyway I'm I'm gonna take lots
of notes off this uh but you've just
released this book like this week I
bought it on Kindle like on Friday or
something I was like oh super tactical
you can see it's really short compared
to the other business uh the other books
it's half the size it's designed to be
tactical and
um it's just about creating that mvp and
that lead generation asset uh by the way
just a quick thing to mention we
actually have a link to score app with a
discount code in the video description
and in the kind of show notes if you
want to check out this kind of lead gen
method that Dan's talking about in this
in in this episode okay so I have an
idea for a business and I want to test
it by creating some sort of questionary
type thing that I can send to people
that I know through Facebook or through
being part of the runners World Forum or
part of yep health.com or whatever check
on the Forum or Chuck it to my Facebook
friends would you be interested in this
sort of thing free scorecard free
questionnaire they put their email
address in at the end yeah I do yeah or
at the beginning or at the end same
thing if you run an event so as I said
my whole First Empire was uh intro
events introduction events and that was
the lead generation and warm-up phase in
one and then scorecards became the
digital version of that always available
24 7 collecting data making
recommendations on autopilot so those
are all lead Generations but they're
also good MVPs so anyone who's got an
idea run an event see if you can fill it
launch a scorecard see if you can get
people taking it and that'll tell you
whether you're going to be any good or
not or whether you've got any chance
yeah to do this do it for maybe four
months in a row and see whether you can
grow it each month because if you get 30
then 20 then 10 then 5 then we're
tracking it in the wrong direction if
you get 30 then 50 then 100 then 150
okay maybe this could take off so you
want a very simple MVP it's just lead
generation at first so all you're trying
to do is can I generate leads because
everything is Downstream from lead
generation so can I generate leads if
you can't generate leads forget about
how good you are as a doctor forget
about how amazing your product is forget
about how well you you know can do it
speaking right all of that doesn't
matter if you can't get the lead so
ultimately the first thing to test is
lead generation can I generate leads for
this idea so what counts as a lead any
signal of Interest okay where
essentially they're giving you some
revealing signal of Interest so buying a
ticket is a reveal it's basically if I
buy a ticket to the magical
life-changing
um Power of a personal assistant and
it's a one-hour Zoom webinar Workshop
clearly I'm the type of person who's
considering a personal assistant so it's
a signal of interest uh name and email
and and and I'm giving you an hour of
time to tell me about this or if I fill
in the scorecard that's a strong signal
of Interest so a lead is just a somebody
reviewing themselves uh to say I'm
interested it's it's that whole hey yeah
I'm interested in that okay that's a
lead so what happens next once you've
got the lead I've got the email address
so that's called your minimum viable
product so the next thing is called
Product Market fit product Market fit is
adjusting the product to meet the market
so you imagined the product would be red
but everyone wants it in blue and you're
like ah okay as much as I thought it
should be red it needs to be blue so
this is where you do product Market fit
work so you want to be the marathon
coach and you imagined that you would be
tweaking everyone's running style but
they all want help with diet they all
want help picking a pair of shoes and
it's like just go down and get a pair of
shoes and like just watch this video on
on diet it's like yeah but that's what
we want and it's like oh okay so I need
to include that in the product
so this is called Product Market fit and
it's essentially making adjustments to
your product so that the product fits
what the market wants so we I think I
accidentally did this well it wasn't
quite accidentally we when launching the
first iteration iteration of our YouTube
of course two years ago we worked with
this marketing coach and he was like
okay send an email to your list being
like what is your biggest challenge with
growing your YouTube channel and see
what happens and then on the second page
of that asking them a few sort of more
qualifying a few more questions and
initially I was imagining our YouTuber
course would be helping people from 100
000 subscribers scale up by Building
Systems and processes and stuff turns
out 95 of the people who filled out the
survey hadn't hadn't even made their
first video and like the other five
percent like we're all under 100
subscribers and we were like what the
hell like this is not what we had in
mind this is more like a YouTube for
complete and utter beginners who have a
job but like don't feel like they have
the time to do YouTube properly and want
to just learn all the yeah oh that's a
very different product too here is how
you can hire and Outsource a team and
build systems and stuff to blow up your
business no it's like Yeah The Old
Market there like we want to get started
and they almost they almost always would
say what equipment do you have and you
might have gone oh well it doesn't
matter but like people love the
equipment they want the equipment thing
so people love templates people love the
whole like what's the template they use
for your videos it's like I mean it's
it's not that hot it's just it's just
it's just these three things but okay
and now people love it they're like oh
my God thank you so much for the
template it's so useful and I'm always a
bit baffled but now I've kind of learned
that's a product Market fit yeah and
product Market fit is often baffling
because your values are different to the
values of someone who's buying the
product because if you're a fitness
trainer you've got Fitness high on your
values and you research it all the time
you read it all the time if you're a
fitness trainer buyer you're buying a
product like that Fitness is low on your
values which is why you're buying yeah
so you basically have a mismatch in
values the things that are quite obvious
to the person who's setting up a
business are actually non-obvious to the
people who are buying from the business
and the things that are highly valuable
over here might be too advanced over
here so there's always going to be a
mismatch and you have to get into that
alignment and that's product Market fit
yeah and that's where I guess you know
our doctor turned coach thinks that
people care about a qualification when
in reality they probably don't like if
or maybe they do but like there's some
level of testing the market to see if
that's if that's actually a thing yeah
well maybe they want a certificate that
you're right you're now certified and
ready to put your first YouTube video up
and you maybe that's important and you
might sit there and go that's so silly
but it's like but I just want to be
certified that I'm ready to start and
it's like okay well we'll here's the
certificate right so that is the all
product Market fit nice and the great
thing about this is that this is all
stuff people can do like in a couple of
hours on a weekend while you have a job
totally like it's not that hard to put
together one of these things yeah on
score I've gone any Google forms or
anything like that and you can probably
whack one together exactly yeah and
you're collecting data you're collecting
signals of Interest you're getting leads
remember my background was like people
ringing 1 800 numbers and uh people
emailing that they would like to attend
so anything like that like you know any
signal of interest is going to be a
powerful signal of interest and then
product Market fit is making adjustments
now the end result of product Market fit
should be a landing page or a brochure
that when you show it to people they go
oh that's cool right so we must we I
know this sounds weird but the end
result for that stage is you now have a
landing page or a brochure
that is the document that shows this is
the offer this is the product it's an
offer form and most people it's like
they they kind of steamroll ahead but
they don't produce that piece of
collateral that police piece of
collateral is a very important step
where people can hold it see it open it
look at it you don't have to like by the
way you you you could create a brochure
for going on a trip to the moon
and it doesn't necessarily have to exist
and you don't have to own rockets and
all of that sort of stuff but you could
say in 2025 I'm going to be partnering
with a rocket company for a trip to the
moon would you would you sign up for
this would you you know does this look
like something you'd want and all it
needs to do is be a brochure that looks
like a trip to the moon brochure and you
know it says trip to the moon right
there and now there's no cost in doing
that right a little bit of time and
design But ultimately you can show
people and they can then go yes I want
that wow yes and and this is I'm just
thinking like this is the exact stuff we
used to do in like uh ICT class in
school of like hey pretend like you're
designing this database and oh let's
make a brochure on Microsoft Publisher
or whatever it was back in the day
around the thing and I guess the
equivalent in the modern world is either
just like whipping up a quick landing
page on like Squarespace or anything
simple even like a Google doc
um this uh a coach person who had
breakfast with was like obsessing over a
WordPress website I was like honestly I
have paid for 10 000 coaching packages
off the back of a Google doc you don't
need the like the thing with where it's
just like the offer later some document
yeah something that I can be like okay
here is the offer and he has how much it
costs oh on that point here's how much
it costs how does do you put the price
on the so there's three documents that
eventually come together there's the
brochure the offer form and the sign up
right so the brochure is all the kind of
story around the product and what's
included the offer form is how much is
it and what do you get specifically now
on a landing page you would have seen if
you hit the pricing button on most
websites and it gives you one of those
drop downs where it says gold silver
bronze and it's tick tick tick cross
that's the offer yeah and the sign up is
where people buy and they put in all
their details and they pay a deposit
um they often they'll pay just a holding
deposit
um for a startup they'll just
um or they'll say you can say
um
we will notify you when this is
available one of the best things you can
do at the MVP level is you can put up a
landing page if people click the buy now
button it says this product's no longer
available in your area or not yet
available in your area join the waiting
list
and then people go okay join the waiting
list that way you don't need payment
gateways you don't need to have credit
card machines or any any of those sorts
of things you're just collecting the
signal that they were willing to pay yes
but you didn't let them is it at all
useful to so we're we're having this
dilemma with our courses where it's like
my instinct was that we should have the
landing page before we even think about
creating the course because then we're
like and we should do the audience
interviews and use that to tweak the
landing page and then we should have
like a pre-order form that gives them
like a big discount or something and uh
so that we in in addition to getting an
idea of how many people click the button
we get an idea of how many people were
willing to pre-order yeah um is that
something that you would just it's so
much better you don't need to do
discounts either demand and Supply
tension push the price up but not down
so for example if you said we're doing a
cohort of 300 and join the waiting list
and if it's transparent that three and a
half thousand people joined the waiting
list and there's only 300 spots you
don't need a discount so transparent
demand and Supply tension pushes prices
up uh so essentially any join the
waiting list or register your interest
or any of that sort of stuff provided
there's a level of transparency to show
the tension
um that will result in high prices not
low prices
okay so I I I I feel like I've like
through through reading your stuff
stumbled Upon A lot of these ideas over
the last several years
but when I think when someone hears
about it for the first time the thought
that you can
sell a thing without having created the
thing is gonna lead to like oh is that
unethical that sounds evil that sounds
bad sound like how it's very evil what's
going on yeah
it's very simple you're either you're
either asking them to attend an
information event
which you're going to deliver an
information event on Zoom or maybe
you're going to book a little room right
board room or something but you're
inviting people to an event and that is
a standalone thing that they can get
some information and learn more about
the topic or you're inviting them to
take a scorecard or a survey and they're
going to hand over some data in exchange
for some feedback right so there's an
ethical exchange or you're inviting them
to join a waiting list where they know
that the product is not yet available
but they're wanting to be included in
information and updates that when they
become available
so Elon Musk knew that cyber truck was
not going to be built for three years
but he launched cyber truck he showed
people what cyber truck would look like
he invited people to put down a hundred
dollar deposit if they wanted to be in
the waiting list for a cyber truck
knowing full well that it wouldn't be
available for three years
uh he collected a million deposits a
million 100 deposits and that allowed
him to raise an unlimited amount of
capital from the market to then go and
fulfill those orders so he was able to
go and build the
factories and he like imagine he hadn't
collected those signals and you go to
JPMorgan and you say hey look we want to
create a cyber truck and this is what it
looks like it's unlike anything that's
ever been built and JP Morgan's gonna go
we can't give you money for a factory
for that but if you go in there and say
a million people have put down 100
deposit it's like great what are the
terms yeah
yeah so so you're not doing anything
unethical it's an event it's a scorecard
or it's a waiting list
where did the name scorecard come from
uh well a quiz typically is testing your
knowledge like if I quiz you on your
Beatles trivia you know I'm testing to
know what you know
um a assessment uh kind of feels like uh
academic
um I just wanted to keep it like a fun
way of discussing cool yeah so it's like
a scorecard it's like should you start a
YouTube channel answer these questions
find out uh take the test uh get a
scorecard and the scorecard is like
because we've set up the software so
that you can have multiple categories so
you could have Diet exercise and sleep
and then it's like oh your diet's strong
your exercise is strong but your sleep
is the weakest so it's that kind of a
scorecard of you know being able to look
at different categories yeah um oh man
I'm gonna make a productivity scorecard
yeah yeah definitely and what categories
would you do
um probably something like
um
do you know where you want to go so like
Vision vision for type stuff uh and then
in terms of like
do you know where you want to go do you
know how you're going to get there so in
terms of like the goal setting so
tactics tactical planning that kind of
stuff and then it's going to be how good
is your uh takeoff so like getting
started with work over going for
procrastination all that kind of stuff
then how good are you at staying and
staying on the course so like not
getting distracted and focused on stuff
and then probably gadgets and tools
right some like people people love
gadgets and tools definitely how strong
are your how strong are your supplies
um something around like to what extent
do you regularly take breaks and
recharge and blah blah blah blah
um so you probably want to have you want
to have three to five categories yep you
want to boil it down to three to five
categories and you want to then do six
questions per category okay all right so
it's 30 questions all up something like
that and then basically when people
answer the 30 questions the scorecard
will then break it into the categories
and it'll say you have no gadgets you're
a zero for gadgets but you're really
high on motivation you've got an amazing
Vision but you're Tactical
implementations low so then you say
great you've got a Clear Vision but we
need to work on your tactics and your
gadgetry and then that gives a clearer
indicator even if I don't make the
specific product of like oh wow loads of
people are really struggle with
motivation cool let's try and make a
video right book to do a thing based on
the exactly Market yeah
love it
okay six so we've got the idea ideation
thingy we've narrowed it down and then
we have built the MVP which is the
scorecard or the event or the webinar on
that note what's the deal with webinars
they have a sort of a bit of a
in my in my mind webinar equals slightly
scammy
um I I guess it's basically change that
yeah um it's just a cheap event that you
can put on you know like I just think of
it as a zoom meeting and you're just
going to present some slides so if I was
launching a new business I'm going to
put on a zoom meeting because I want to
reduce the amount of time that it takes
for people to jump on or jump off if
they don't like it
um so I might say hey I'm a doctor I
want to do
um a lecture on what we've been learning
around gut health
um let's say so I'm going to do an
introduction to weight loss through
better gut health uh would you like to
jump on it's going to be a 45 minute
lecture
um jump on Zoom you don't have to travel
anywhere you don't have to catch a train
you don't have to do any of that so it's
a zoom meeting so
yeah look any tool can be used for
scammy Stuff uh you a boardroom they're
probably board rooms full of scammers
right now right but
um but it doesn't mean there's anything
wrong with the boardroom yeah uh so it's
just a zoom meeting it's low low cost
for you low friction for them uh and
it's just an easy way to test the market
because if you can get 30 people on that
webinar but half of them drop off
um during the webinar then it's like
okay something's wrong so it's giving
you feedback and that's all we're after
at the beginning so MVP product Market
fit the next one's called go to market
okay go to market is where you're now
pushing sales and marketing on uh you
might raise some money to go to market
um it's a very easy to raise go to
market money because you've done your
MVP you've got your data you've got your
testing and now the data says we should
go all in on this so now it's go to
market when people think about starting
a business they normally mentally jump
to go to market so it's like oh I need
to go and talk to people and quit my job
and all that sort of stuff and they
haven't done those first few steps so go
to market is where you turn on all your
lead generation uh you might spend money
on ads you might do joint ventures and
promotions you're hustling you're making
sales you might hire a team at that
point you might hire a salesperson so
that's all the go to market activity
your your
um probably going from testing Revenue
maybe you've earned 50 Grand testing and
now you're going to earn 500 000 or a
million where do the testing Revenue
come in well you might have had people
put down deposits or you might have just
taken on like let's say well for example
when we build score app
I did like a dozen people who paid eight
grand each for their scorecard and we
built it on WordPress and we literally
just
charge them the full amount to build it
from scratch each time
um and that's because there was no
platform that's how much it cost
um so we probably earned 80 to 100 Grand
worth of um people paying for a setup
but it was a Hands-On setup yeah yeah it
seems like a lot of startups do this
where
um
you sign up to the thing but in the
early days it's someone on a Google
sheet who's like doing the thing yeah I
know they're going to build a software
at some point but yeah at least they've
got someone on a Google sheet doing the
thing that is the most successful
startups yeah that's that's how it's
done that's how the professionals do it
by the way a lot of the time the
amateurs think that the professionals go
and build this amazing all singing all
dancing thing and then sell it it's
absolutely not the more professional the
entrepreneur the more likely they are to
be just like putting together slide
decks and making the sale and then doing
a Hands-On one at a time sale to see how
the customer is interacting at every
single step
um and you know you might want to create
a productivity app and you literally
have a Google sheet and you have a
person who Rings up and says have you
done your Google sheet today and let's
go through it together jump on and we'll
both do it and it's like oh this isn't
an app it's a Google sheet it's like
that's a pro you know that that's a pro
entrepreneur amateur entrepreneur will
get the families 300 Grand mortgage the
house like you know Grandma's monies in
it and then like they built this all
singing all dancing piece of technology
that nobody's ever going to use
um
nice
yeah I think uh so uh
personal trainers who do like online
personal training and stuff
um
I I feel like there's this thing where
it's like
they're they're going to give you the
programming or something like that but
it's probably just like a Google sheet
template that they just use for all
their clients and maybe at some point
there's like a sophisticated level of
like
um customization but realistically
everyone broadly needs the same plan so
like yeah yeah and a lot of the time
people want hand holding they want
support they want accountability
um so what they're providing is those
those types of things but once again
that is a self-employed
um freelancer type model uh so it's not
so much like what we're discussing is
that world of the entrepreneur building
the scalable solution and building a
business that will eventually have value
because ultimately an entrepreneur
Builds an asset and the reason
entrepreneurs can sell their business is
they have an asset and the asset salable
and that's the difference self-employed
people aren't really building an asset
uh they're they're selling labor so
um this is a pathway to that exitable
salable scalable asset people who have
work-life balance are underpinned by
assets so the reason I might have work
life balances because I've got
best-selling books that are selling like
it's weird I sell a few books an hour
every hour around the clock and that is
like a relationship engine always
running and people are learning about
what we do and who we are without me
having to physically be anywhere so
that's called an asset an asset has been
developed and then the asset Works
online scorecards we we generated 90 000
leads on autopilot and that those those
were always coming in we automatically
connected those to a salesperson so when
a lead came in a salesperson Got a
notification and then they pick up the
phone talk to that person make a sale so
I can be anywhere in the world
um that is underpinning yourself with
assets so what we're talking about with
entrepreneurship is the creation of an
asset uh that that does the work
intellectual property Media or Tech is
normally the the primary assets that we
work with as entrepreneurs is
intellectual property media and
Technology
right so again I'm thinking I'm thinking
to my hypothetical productivity course
for example
um the assets are the YouTube videos
that media plug the scorecard yeah which
based on intellectual property so the IP
the scorecard is technology the video is
a media and your approach to it is
intellectual property and then every day
x number of people will fill out the
scorecard probably because I'll just
plug it's a free scorecard it's easy to
plug in a video without seeming like
semi in any way this like literally just
a free scorecard of the people that are
sufficiently then qualified through the
scorecard we could then either do a
frictionless sale of like you you would
love the online course yep or do a where
does where does a Salesman fit into this
into this equation salesperson typically
fits with any sale that is north of a
couple of thousand
um because just by virtue of the fact
that there's a spend normally requires
some trust and some customization and
conversation so if you were doing a
productivity rollout with a corporate
and they were thinking about doing this
with 70 of their employees is then that
would normally involve some form of
sales conversation it's unlikely that
the NHS would roll out a 70 person trial
on productivity without talking to
someone first so
essentially when there's a commitment
normally for things that are less than a
thousand and that have a free trial
um you know any of those types of things
you don't normally need a salesperson
you can do it through media but once we
go into the thousands most people want
to talk to someone and and that's where
a salesperson fits in and then when the
leads come in that sales person can talk
to them and identify you know and
reassure and give the right information
you know because you're taking if a
salesperson is good they live and
breathe this product and service they
understand all the complexity and all
the moving parts and then the person's
got their narrow set of needs and the
salesperson is essentially sharing with
them these are the features advantages
benefits that are relevant for you
so our YouTuber Academy course is now
north of two thousand dollars uh so like
two grand I think three grand and Seven
Grand is three different packages and
I've always sort of thought especially
after reading over subscribed hmm do we
would it be useful to have a sales
function well you'd probably find that
you could add a million a year just
through a salesperson so if you've got
warm leads there are plenty of people
who are they've already signaled their
intent that they want to do this the
only reason they're not buying is
they're just not sure but I would I
would hypothesize that the number one
reason people don't buy is they don't
feel confident themselves that they will
be the right person to do the work and
if you focus your energy on having a
salesperson who can listen to what their
idea is
show them some case studies or examples
of people who've had a similar idea help
them to identify that yes there's a
market for what you're talking about
well no there's not and then just do a
little bit of reassurance and then maybe
offer some sort of a guarantee period
where you say hey look it sounds like
you need to test this idea
if you knew this would work would it be
a silly decision to spend two grand on
this no I could do that okay great so
what if we have a guarantee period where
we do some testing and if you can get
more than 50 people to subscribe to your
channel that's enough of a test in month
one to know it's a good idea and then
you're happy to spend the two grand yeah
okay great so anything less than 50
people subscribed we'll we'll refund the
money if it goes over 50 if you've done
the work you've uploaded these videos
you've got your 50 subscribers then
you're happy right so a little bit of
that conversation you probably find that
you can make a sale a day uh 200 days of
the year there's another 400 000 you
know and up
that could be quite fun um yeah and it
could be a good service right it's it's
thinking it's radical empathy for the
person who's buying yeah it's like is
this genuinely useful for the so so like
last time we did like two cohorts ago I
was uh we we sort of did like a zoom
webinari top on a zoom call I was
available for an hour like four times a
day just to answer people's questions
about the thing but what I found was
that like I know 20 people would show up
15 of them would have the cameras off
most of them were were like younger
people that were never gonna sign up I
just wanted to see what I was like on a
zoom call and it just ended up being not
really helpful
um is that where you then start
qualifying leads and have one-on-one
conversations and stuff yeah so you'd
probably have a salesperson who does an
email out and says hey I'd love to talk
to you about your YouTube channel
um would you like to have a chat here's
a link to my diary people then book A
Time In The Diary maybe it's a 20 minute
30 minute slot
um tell me about what kind of YouTube
channel you'd like to launch tell me
where are you at a new youtubing Journey
right at the beginning I've got a
hundred thousand followers right who
knows or maybe this the scorecard's
already told you so it's like hey a
scorecard says that you've got 5 000
plus followers tell me a bit about how
did you get there so what are you
looking to do next what help do you
think we can offer what made you signal
your interest in in our product
um what held you back what stopped you
from going ahead with it
um oh okay so you were just going away
on a holiday and the timing didn't work
what about now oh no you're fine now
okay great I'm glad I called you let's
get you set up so you know those things
happened all the time and sometimes
people will be too scared to ask you a
question because it's you you're the
figurehead you're the key person of
influence so they might just be too
nervous to ask a silly question
but they'll ask you a salesperson
yeah and like the the cool thing about
this I think is that the ability to just
offer someone a phone call it's
something that again anyone anyone can
do even when they have a job like I I
just the the amount of people that I
speak to who are like I want to do the
side hustle thing but I have a job or
I'm a full-time student and and like
I've only got a few hours on a weekend
and and sort of there's this impression
that people have that they have to do
this mountain of work over a period of
several years before they can get any
anywhere at all but actually this
process of come up with the ideas MVP
with the scorecard or with a zoom event
or whatever get you know the product
Market fit hop on a phone call with some
people who just actually figure out what
their problems are and be like you know
would you be willing to pay x amount for
this thing yep yeah it feels very doable
it's all doable yeah the hard part is go
to market and scale and exit so the next
three steps is what we think of as
entrepreneurship which is go to market
which is ramp you know turn on the Jets
uh let's go for it let's hire a team A
salesperson all of that sort of stuff
it's all go to market strategy
um scale is multiple locations now we're
going to go out in so we might start in
London and then go go out to Los Angeles
and New York and different locations so
we're going to go scale is normally new
products new markets new territories so
we're going to scale out and then exit
is let's sell this business and go again
so when we think of entrepreneurs we
think go to market scale up exit yeah
but actually the first three steps are
very doable which is ideation
minimum viable product and product
Market fit amazing all right so we've
talked a lot about these sort of first
these first few stages of the
entrepreneur Revolution becoming
entrepreneur I think we'll leave the
entrepreneur subject there because most
people as we get the other list like the
amount of people that scale up and go to
market and exit is relevant to like
dwindles but I'd love to hear like
what's it like for you
um
you now run a company that has like 100
plus employees and you own multiple
businesses and you're
living with wife and kids in London it
seems like you're living the dream dream
life what's what's that like and I'm
asking from a selfish perspective
because I'm trying to figure out what
does my career look like
10 15 20 years later and
at the moment I see examples of black
people like Tim Ferriss and Ryan holiday
who do their content thing and writing a
book occasionally it seems good but I
haven't really spoken to many people
that do the seem to be living their best
life with wife and kids while owning
multiple businesses and stuff so yeah
what's it like well Wife and Kids is the
best thing ever right
um so you know that's the for me that's
the thing that really completes life and
makes it all worthwhile and makes the
journey uh all the ups and downs just
pale in comparison to when you get the
family and the family home and all of
those sorts of things
um so uh what well what's interesting is
that no matter what level of wealth
you're at uh when you have little kids
life becomes very different you very
boring all right routine based it can be
a massive challenge to your identity in
your in your ego
um sudden well suddenly the whole world
is not you um suddenly you don't matter
at all so
you you go from being the center of the
um your ego Universe to being a second
you know a supporting act to the center
of the world especially when children
are very very young and need a lot of
care and attention your partner will be
very focused on them
um and right now you take it very much
for granted that you can roll out of bed
whenever you want and go for a breakfast
somewhere and you can change your mind
about something and you can just simply
jump on a plane and go on holiday once
you've got kids
you know all of that is logistics and
you know you find yourself with uh
Nanny's bigger house bigger car
um Logistics all of that stuff starts to
her so it's a different it's a different
life
um it's a very good life it's it's
lovely
um and I recommend it uh I think life
moves in chapters and I had an amazing
chapter in my 20s which was the globe
trotting entrepreneur making millions
and running team and partying and and
all of that sort of stuff
um you know I had a different chapter in
my 30s building a Global business as
well and you know uh in my 30s I wrote
best-selling books I spoke on big stages
I got paid tens of thousands of pounds
to give a one-hour talk regularly I got
to share the stage with my heroes like
Richard Branson and people like that
Richard Branson follows me on Twitter by
the way which is he only follows a
couple of people and it's like that
stuff
um and uh and then in my late 30s early
40s I'm now the Family Guy
um so we've got the big house and we
spend a lot of time at the big house and
we go to the park and we you know we
little things are big things getting on
the swings is a big thing
um and uh you know overcoming a fear of
a dog uh that comes up and sniffs you is
a big thing so
um you know that my whole world now
revolves around this chapter a very
different chapter
so what does
now that you're in the in this chapter
what does your work life look like
so I live a fairly normal work life now
I have work-life balance
um I arrived at that place so I
typically start my day at 9 30 and I
finish my day around 5 5 30.
um and a lot of the time I have nothing
to do during the day so I might go out
for lunch with my wife and
um I might pick I'd often drop the kids
at school and often pick them up from
school
um and
um you know I might sit and play
computer games with the kids and and all
that sort of stuff so I have a lot of
that going on
um
yeah so how how much do you care now at
this point about making more money
like professional success and like how
yeah
so for me making more money is more
about the fact that I've acquired a set
of skills and I like using those skills
right I'm really good at buying and
selling companies for example I'm really
good at I've done seven Acquisitions
I've done several exits
um and you know the the cool thing with
entrepreneurship
is that it really starts getting going
at 40 and you start getting really good
at 40 and you know your career goes from
strength to strength after 40. I felt it
was a little sad Roger Federer you know
he just retired and he has to retire
because his body can't keep up with the
demand of tennis so career ends at 40.
um whereas entrepreneurs don't really
get going statistically until they're
early 40s so one of the things that I
really enjoy is that now I've got a set
of resources and team and data and
skills that actually I can get a lot
done uh in a fairly short space of time
right because now I've got the leverage
but when I think about making money
um it's really
I don't think a lot about making money
but I do think a lot about leveraging
that set of skills and creating fun
things
um and having fun projects I also love
doing
um businesses in partnership with people
especially I love doing Partnerships uh
like co-founding with slightly younger
people
bringing them
um you know up in in their
entrepreneurial Journey
so it sounds like you're mostly
motivated by like the enjoyment the love
of the craft the infinite game that
you're playing around like hey this
business thing is cool I like building
and growing selling businesses that's
yeah well my my infinite game is to
develop entrepreneurs who Stand Out
scale up and make a positive impact
that's my infinite game so I do that
through my accelerator programs we
develop entrepreneurs who Stand Out
scale up and have purpose at the heart
of their business and we've done that
with three and a half thousand companies
around the world now score app is a
piece of technology that solves the
number one problem that people have
which is the lead generation problem so
it allows them to stand out scale up and
start making a difference
um and on my accelerators I often put
heads of social Charities and change
projects and put them through and we
like I do one-to-one coaching with
people who could be a key person of
influence in a way that really changes
the world
um so yeah look I have a bunch of fun
um because if you have a set of skills
you want to use those skills you it
feels right that you've drawn to use
those skills because it's like oh you
know I'm you know if you like if you're
a ballroom dancer and you're really good
at dancing you want to dance
um if you're a guitarist and you're
really good at guitar you want to pick
up the guitar and play so if you're if
you're an entrepreneur and you start
figuring out how this crazy world of
Entrepreneurship actually works yeah you
want to talk about it you want to do it
you want to buy and sell stuff you want
to scale stuff yeah one of my coaches
asked a few weeks ago he he asked me you
know the thought experiment of
What would life look like if I wasn't if
I I just was not allowed to create
anything on the internet for the next
like two years and I was like okay I
mean fair enough I guess I do loads of
reading getting into philosophy and
economics and politics I'm interested
reading all that kind of stuff and then
when the two-year Market is up then I
can distill all that stuff and that
would be super fun and then he was like
okay what if you're not allowed to do
anything on the internet any kind of
teaching on the internet for the rest of
your life I was like oh damn I'd be
really depressed like I guess I'd I
don't know try and do it in like in real
like teaching in real life and host like
lectures and stuff but it just that made
me realize that for me the infinite game
is teaching like learning cool stuff and
teaching it learning how life Works
sharing it with others and helping
improve their lives right so that's who
you are and that's that speaks to your
identity and and all of that the risk
can be that your strong suit can become
um overused you can be a ballerina who
dances until your feet bleed
um you know so one thing that is a risk
is um
when you discover
how great life can be with fun freedom
and flexibility built in you often
become very picky about your partner who
you're going to settle down with and
have kids with and all that sort of
stuff so therefore you get a lot of
people like Tim Ferriss bless him but
he's notoriously
um single and Footloose Fancy free and
not having kids and all that sort of
stuff which is I get it it's kind of
cool I was I was that guy right but um
but there can be this risk that you've
got your life set up so well that you
don't want to disrupt it with a partner
or kids so that can be where you're
winning your winning strategy becomes
your losing strategy have you come
across this book called uh the second
Mountain no it sounds like a cool it's
by the I think it's by David Brooks uh
is the thesis is that in life there are
two mountains the first mountain is the
mountain of success and status and
financial success and doing all the
stuff and then you get to the summit and
realize that that's not where lasting
happiness is or you get chucked off the
mountain by like a health scare or
someone dying or something like that and
you realize that there is a second
mountain and while the first Mountain
was the mountain of like happiness the
second mountain is the mountain of joy
and while the first Mountain was all
about optimizing for freedom and fun fun
and flexibility the second mountain is
all about like actually I really want to
invest I want to commit I want to build
a home I want to give myself to a cause
that I really care about and you know
getting off that first Mountain onto the
second is like you know people it's
great I can relate to that I think it's
a great philosophy and uh yeah you don't
want you don't want to just keep
climbing up and down this same Mountain
it's like it's you know you're
constantly searching for that new high
of fun Freedom flexibility because I see
a lot of people I'm in the space where I
do come across a lot of people who have
done that but
um you know I I think that it's hard
it's hard to say because you only really
kind of fall in love with your kids
after they're born and after their I
think it might be different to be on a
certain age or certain months I think
too maybe there's a difference between
men and women I think men don't
necessarily naturally love the idea of
kids but once you have them then it's
like oh now I get it yeah
um yeah every dude I know who else kids
has that kind of vibe that like yeah
back in the day we were talking to
Gordon about this the other day yeah
like you know when people show you
photos of their kids you're like what
the hell yeah and then you get kids and
then you start showing people photos of
your kids you become that Dad yeah yeah
exactly so
I think it's important to have the
second Mountain you know and the other
thing too is so I have a friend of mine
sold a company for
um 900 million right and cash yeah and
has gone on to build several more
businesses and I totally understand and
and they're worth hundreds of millions I
totally understand and he's also my age
right I get that he's got this
incredible unique set of skills for
building extremely valuable businesses
but hasn't at all gone for the second
mountain and you know he's all about
optimizing businesses and optimizing
teams and building another 100 million
dollar company
but I sit there with my family and I
think I'm actually really happy I'm on
this second Mountain my first Mountain's
going quite well but you know I get more
joy from the the second one
amazing done thank you so much this has
been absolutely wonderful I will put
links to all of the books in uh in the
video description in the show notes uh
any final asks of our viewers or
listeners uh final ask is this my mentor
said to me Daniel don't watch the news
you live in the most incredible time you
couldn't have been born at a better time
um this is an amazing moment in history
don't ruin it by looking at all the
horrible things that happened today
um so ask number one is see if you can
tune out from the news and spend more
time doing positive things and see if
you can tune into the fact that the
world is actually a really amazing place
right now and there's so many great
things that you can be doing and there's
so many great opportunities and
um and that the the world is a big
positive Place think about
if all of humanity got to vote
what you should be doing with this
amazing life that you've got what would
they want you to do based upon you know
if they could observe you and and see
you know what they want you to do
um I think it's an incredible time to be
an entrepreneur there's more money than
ever before there's more talented people
there's more technology this is an
incredible time to be an entrepreneur so
you know study it learn it get some
mentors get some people around you and
and go for it this is this is the moment
amazing thank you so much
cheers thanks for having me all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye